so Jordan Peterson got suspended on
Twitter for making a tweet about an
actress with the last name Paige I'll
just put it that way who's in the
Umbrella Academy he made a tweet
referencing an individual named Ellen
Page who now goes by Elliot page how
does that work for you and is refusing
to apologize so it looks like it's going
to be a permanent suspension but there
is really really big news Jordan
Peterson uh and Dennis Prager have
signed with the daily wire the daily
wire announced they got 890 000 paying
subscribers and uh I was so jealous I
punched my monitor I was like oh the
daily one no I'm just kidding I'm really
excited for these guys because their
Victory is our Victory watching the
corporate press and the establishment
fizzle out and implode CNN plus couldn't
even fail on time they ended up
imploding a few days early it's amazing
and then the daily wire is taking off to
see all of this success to see Jordan
Peterson getting more funding to see
money coming in to see everyone
supporting the daily wire it's just good
news it's just all around good news and
then because it's not all good news so I
decided you know we're originally going
to leave with the Joe Biden story where
he said you're going to pay high gas
prices as long as it takes for him to uh
win in Ukraine great Joe Biden's
political Ambitions are going to dictate
why you can't afford to pay for gas but
you know I decided it is a little dark
and uh you know let's switch it up and
talk about the good news I mean it is
kind of bad news that Jordan Peterson
got suspended we'll talk about that plus
we got some crazy news
the EPA is lost in the Supreme Court
Supreme Court basically said the EPA
can't regulate carbon emissions which is
a huge knock on federal Authority so now
it's just hilarious all of the losses
the left has received gun rights Roe v
Wade and now the EPA they are freaking
out
and you'll see of course going on
Colbert and saying the Supreme Court's
illegitimate or whatever see the extreme
at Nancy place as their extremists well
they're really really upset but the
Democrats are going to use all of that
energy to try and win in the midterms
we'll see because I'm not convinced
after all of the really bad stuff that
happened to the left because the Supreme
Court made correct rulings
when Joe Biden comes out and says you're
going to pay high gas prices as long as
it takes I'm pretty sure people are
going to be like as long as it takes is
until you're voted out of office dude
because it's not going to be that long
so we'll talk about all that but before
we get started head over to timcast.com
and become a member to help support our
work the daily wire has 890 000
subscribers so we just need to add about
800 and some odd thousand people to our
website and then we can be as big as
they are but uh we're doing a lot of
stuff here uh as well we brought in
Jamie kilstein to help us do the uh the
Vlog cast Castle which we're we're
slowly building it up to kind of like a
fictional version of the of of our
office so it'll be like a sitcom with
gags and bits we've always been trying
to do that but you have to slowly build
up to it and we're not just throwing
tons of money into it but with your
support we can ramp up production across
the board we got Tales from the inverted
World launching season two tomorrow it's
gonna be big plus the book so we got a
bunch of stuff in the works we've got
new people coming on board we've got new
shows planned and with your support as
members there won't just be one massive
company taking over the cultural
establishment there will be two Tim Cass
will be doing it as well so sign up
we're gonna have a members only show
coming up for you at 11 p.m that will be
at timcast.com smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends without further Ado
joining us to talk about all of these
fun stories is Spike Cohen hey man
thanks for having me on who are you I am
Spike Cohen I am uh the founder and
chair of an organization I started about
a month ago called you are the power
which is a Grassroots libertarian
political activism group uh I am uh a
retired business owner uh I am first and
foremost uh the husband who objectively
the greatest woman to ever uh walk this
planet Tasha Cohen uh and uh in my spare
time I Cyberbully federal agencies and
uh elected officials until they delete
their social media accounts has that
actually happened a few times yeah oh
wow we've got I think 12 total uh uh
mostly local in state but yeah a few
DA's we've chased off the internet and
stuff but you don't mean like literally
Cyberbully you mean challenge they're
Authority yeah so I should say cyber
bullyism we don't threaten or anything
like that but really just uh I'm
actually
um almost
um like
sacker and sweet in the way I'm like hi
there how are you doing by the way can
we talk about this thing and so I'm I'm
almost I'm very congenial about it but
in a way that makes them want to leave
the internet forever so it should be
it'll be interesting talking about the
EPA stuff with you especially sure
absolutely yeah we also have Mary Morgan
oh thank you for having me on a second
time I didn't say anything to get you
canceled last time I'm still in your
good graces right so you earned your way
back on yeah I'm the co-host of Pop
Culture crisis so I'm gonna shill it all
night tonight we just got over 30 000 so
now it's the race to 40 000 with
inverted world one hundred thousand
eventually pop culture crisis is one of
our shows so Mary and Brett dasovic host
the show yes talking about pop culture
issues and and cultural issues as well
it's the more it's the more cultural
side of the conversation so we talk a
lot about heavy politics and stuff like
the EPA and Joe Biden and you guys were
talking about like woke Hollywood stuff
yeah uh today we were talking about how
James Bond is getting a reinvention
which could mean something very bad he's
gonna be a black woman I think right uh
yeah maybe paraplegic too I heard no
really no
I I believe can you believe it it does a
lot yeah all right uh what's up
everybody uh I'm actually gonna be on
pop culture crisis tomorrow with Mary
and Brett I'm looking forward to it it's
gonna be 3 P.M Eastern Standard Time so
come and check it out and uh I'm looking
forward to communicating tonight with
with compassion not letting my emotions
get the best of me just listening well
not just listening but listening in
addition to talking yes
excellent strategy pop culture crisis is
100 a house like hobby I'm always on on
Wednesday sometimes I go on with Andy
Ian's on Fridays got a bunch of our
journalists on there it's always a good
time you guys should for sure check it
out let's get to 40K next yeah all right
let's jump to this first story from the
National Post Jordan Peterson suspended
from Twitter so somebody might as well
be a band because I won't apologize
quote if I can't be let back on because
I won't apologize I could care less
Jordan Peterson told the National Post
if your Twitter suspended his account
over a tweet about Elliot page I don't
think Jordan Peterson said anything
about Elliott page he did not know he
was referring to an Ellen Page
on June 28th a controversial author I
like how they say is controversial
clinical psychologist and professor
emeritus at the University of Toronto
lost access to most of his Twitter
account features because of a tweet he
posted earlier in the week that used
transgender actor Elliot Page's former
name and suggested he had his breasts
removed by a criminal physician so that
see he said quote I penned an irritated
tweet in response to one of the latest
happenings on the increasingly heated
culture War Front Peter told the
national post as far as Peterson is
concerned the temporary suspension might
as well have been a ban because he would
rather die than delete the tweet in
question he said it does the Tweet stay
up when that happens I think so I'm
gonna have to check it out private I
think it's private they want you to be
the one to take it down to admit you're
wrong
that's a very psychological move it's
like no one can see it but you have to
remove it yourself like we could remove
it but you have to do it or you can't
come back very interesting yeah yeah
like making a kid go out into the woods
and pick his own switch yeah it is very
much yes but I think it's a legal thing
I think it's a legal thing is it yeah I
think they're like we can't tell
liability yeah like we can't we can't
remove it because I'm we're directly
involved or something like also then
where's the proof if you're like Hey
where's your proof that I violated the
terms there's nothing up right but then
there's also I mean like Facebook's
removed all sorts of stuff I put up over
the years and I'm sure Twitter's
actually been fairly good to me on most
stuff but but in terms of I mean I think
they can remove stuff but maybe only if
it's like you said violating the terms
and if this is something that doesn't
technically violate their terms they're
like okay well we're just gonna make you
remove it I'm honestly not sure what it
is I it also might be because he's so
prominent they don't want to remove it
they want him to remove it and make that
you know like atonement for it I
honestly don't know if this was a small
account
but I think the principal issue as to
why he got suspended was because he said
criminal he said criminal physician I
think is what he said right is that what
he said what's his exact tweet position
right and that's it right there the
insinuation of a crime or something is
probably why they took it down okay yeah
not dead naming no no answer policy
I issued a tweet tweet like so so often
when people get suspended for stuff like
this I will tweet something out similar
in the same vein but specifically like
jumping over the landmines of the rules
yeah so that I can effectively say
something similar but to prove a point
kind of just like make make the point
yeah I didn't get suspended maybe maybe
I don't knock on wood smoke too soon but
uh after I heard that Jordan Peterson
got suspended I tweeted who is Ellen
Page and what does breast removed mean
yeah so by posing it as a question the
issue is with you know YouTube and other
all these platforms they don't want you
attacking people that's the real issue
they don't mind you criticizing people
but what Twitter Youtube and other
platforms have said you know behind the
scenes or I mean actually they say it
overtly is their goal is a healthier
conversation
so if you're being critical of someone
but you're doing it calmly they're fine
with it but if you start calling names
and stuff then that's when they so you
think it was more about the the criminal
accusation than about uh calling uh
Elliott Ellen it's it's it's it's kind
of vague but the idea is
these big social media platforms they
don't want to cultivate a culture around
everyone throwing rocks and mud at each
other right so I talked to Google
and they told me because like you know
we have Google Partners I actually know
a ton of people work at Google and they
said we're trying to just clamp down on
people who are angry nasty people who
make their shows based on just being
nasty and mean right and they were like
obviously your show is nothing like that
so you have nothing to worry about and I
was like I mean I don't believe you uh
to be completely honest but I appreciate
you said that to me right right just as
a side note I looked up the terms of
service or Twitter and it says they do
prohibit targeting others with repeated
slurs tropes other content that intends
to dehumanize to Greater reinforce
negative harmful stereotypes this
includes targeted misgendering or dead
naming so I think that might have been
what did so that might have been it not
sure yeah so if you're a small account
on Twitter you get no benefit of the
doubt right of course they just nuke you
in two seconds I don't care for Jordan
Peterson
if if if if the you know the Crim
putting criminal in there I think is
what put him over the edge of they're
saying like you're you're attacking
you're right you know being mean and
nasty or something like that yeah yeah I
don't think it was the dead naming it
probably played a role probably couldn't
help but I don't think Jordan Peterson
knows who Elliot page is or anything
about that you know what I mean right I
think he just saw something it was like
I can't believe they did this what I'm
gonna tweet about it it's a criminal and
then they were like you're gone yeah
yeah so that it might have been the the
dead naming that got their attention but
the you know the letter of the rule that
was broken was the criminal accusation
yeah here's an interesting question
right
it is true that for a while
YouTube Twitter and Facebook and big
social media platforms we're seeing a
lot of people become very prominent off
of just being really nasty
now the problem is the left is still
extremely nasty and they get away with
it all the time
so I recognize it's a problem my problem
is like maybe you guys should
um actually actually do something to to
calm people down and Foster healthier
conversations instead of just Banning
conservatives
yeah this is why last night we talked
about Christianity I brought up like The
Cult of Christianity I think when you're
criticizing a cult it's different than
criticizing the individuals if you're
criticizing the tenets of a cult like
the transgender ideologies of like I was
born in a male body but I want to call
myself a woman now if you question that
that's really not a big problem if you
go after the individuals that are
experiencing it then you're on hot water
like he brought up Ellen's or Elliot's
name Ellen Page Elia page and now that's
like yo now you're bringing someone into
it an innocent bystander almost a part
someone that's part of it yeah I think
there's something to be said a
difference between someone giving their
in their mind principal take either way
on the transgender debate or discussion
and like for example on the on the anti
side you know going after you know
making fun of suicide rates or something
and and you know uh going after
individual people with memes about
suicide or something like that that goes
over the line of having a discussion
about their disagreement with the idea
of gender not being tied to biological
sex and actually saying well I'm gonna
attack this person so that would be an
example of that and obviously there are
other examples on the other side as well
but you know it's the difference between
having even a heated debate and going at
someone personally like you said to your
point attacking them well here's here's
an issue
Jordan Peterson has a lot of very very
important things to say least of which
is his comments about Elliott pages
right should he just say fine delete the
Tweet so he can carry on saying the more
important things to his 2.8 million
followers this is this is the challenge
I think Jordan should probably set up a
truth Social account or something where
he can tweet all day about these ideas
right but not give up the battlefield
over this one thing it's it's tough
isn't it that's a judgment call for him
to make he has to it really comes down
to he has to decide how important what
he was trying to say in that tweet was
right like is that worth giving that up
and it's not just what's in that tweet
but the idea of
something that Jordan Peterson has said
a lot is uh I'm not going to say uh
something that I don't agree with just
because it'll make things easier so if
that's you know the hill he's willing to
die on even if it's not necessarily in
and of itself that important he may back
away from the whole thing and that's you
know I'm not even saying that that's
that I agree with with that decision
being made but you know he's the one
that built that platform or built that
audience and it was on that kind of
principle so it's it's a tough It's a
judgment call man like if he asked me
what would I what should I do I'd not
sure I'd have a good answer for him it
feels like a metaphor for this would be
or some kind of example Jordan Peterson
they swept the leg they knocked him down
and he says you're not supposed to sweep
the leg so I'm done I'm done fighting
and it's like whoa whoa whoa whoa you
didn't lose the fight's still happening
yeah don't walk away just because they
pulled a cheap shot right get up and try
and win
and so the concern I have here is I get
that it was bad that they're censoring
him he should be allowed to express
these ideas they should not be censored
but if Jordan Peterson has a million
important things to say and one of them
got him knocked down
it's not only did he say it
what he said has been blasted off a
million fold everyone's seen it yeah
it's been seen substantially more than
ever before and he can say I got my
message out there let's get back to work
yeah so that that's the challenge with
the censorship issue is everybody's
saying like we shouldn't be on YouTube
and I'm like retreat from the
battlefield so that we can go into a
high school parking lot and talk to no
one yeah or recognize there are certain
things that will get us kicked off the
battlefield and we gotta fight with with
what you know space we have yeah and
then we set up the timcast.com you know
members only show so that we can try and
still do this we are working on stuff
behind the scenes in terms of
infrastructure just we can only go as
fast as humans can go but hopefully
we'll have some big announcements coming
soon and um I think I I kind of feel
like Jordan's made his point he can come
back on Twitter and he can start smack
talking again you should go for it I
think you made a good point Spike that
he's made kind of his career around her
big part of his career is like I'm not
gonna use compel you cannot compel me to
say something I don't believe and in
this situation I think if he did recant
and say okay fine I fine I'll do
whatever you want I'll bend the knee
that he'll lose 40 30 of his followers
or like they'll just lose faith in him
and right now he's got the faith of
Humanity on his side so wherever he goes
whatever he does people will listen
people will follow he he also could be
um playing the long game of expecting
Elon Musk to purchase Twitter so he can
come back triumphant however many weeks
months from now and say see look I
didn't I didn't bend I said what I said
and I'm not going to back off and you
know you can take that to the bank that
I'll never back off of of something that
I believe
um and you know if that ends up uh if
that ends up playing out that way then
uh he ended up playing a much longer
game than the rest of us here's an idea
he can uh take his tweet down and then
ish and then as soon as his account is
reopened issue a new tweet saying follow
me on Truth social because screw this
platform of censorious
as many of their users off the platform
as possible to make them suffer yeah
that's one way to do it I mean look if
Jordan Peterson's saying he's going to
Nuke he's never coming back to Twitter
it's like all right give him one one
final show come back on and be like come
on everybody parties out here let's get
out of here and delete your own account
and then or you just put
yeah yeah that's that's what you got to
do it man do Minds truth socials Trump
will ban you for talking crap about him
on Facebook that's true I have to give a
shout out to my friend Reid Coverdale
because what he does is whenever a new
you know so-called Free Speech platform
comes out he immediately goes on creates
an account and says a bunch of stuff
that that you know takes conservatives
off and so you know immediately go on
there and be like you know uh I I I'm
not even sure if I should say this stuff
because we're streaming on YouTube but
uh saying a bunch of various things that
might uh uh tick people off on the
center right and see how quickly it
takes him to get kicked off and it's
it's usually measured in minutes or
hours
um and uh and so he says you know these
typically and I'm not sure about truth
social uh particularly but in general
um any of these things it's typically
it's more not necessarily free speech in
in entirely but more conservative
friendly speech as opposed to the other
the Twitter version where it's more
Progressive or Centrist friendly speech
um he has a he has a so far in uh he's
batting a thousand for getting knocked
off these platforms shout out to Reed
Coverdale yes nice job let's talk about
what's going on with Jordan Peterson man
this is Jordan Peterson news day daily
wire the new streaming service daily
wire plus signed Jordan Peterson to a
multi-year deal
I was laughing all night so this news
came out uh basically during our show
yesterday and then when I found out I
started laughing I'm like this is
amazing no CNN plus couldn't last three
weeks they were supposed to implode
within a month and then even a few days
early they couldn't even fail on time
and watching there just collapse then
CNN had this announcement that like
their daytime host was like I'm quitting
I'm tired of being tired I don't want to
do this anymore and then daily wire is
expanding rapidly they're signing new
shows they're launching new shows
they're they're bringing in Dennis
Prager and Jordan Peterson in April they
had 600 000 subscribers now they have
890 000 subscribers and so it was just a
good day you know what I say
I'll say this earlier I'm not motivated
by money I'm not doing this because I
want to buy a Ferrari a Lambo and build
a mansion if that no I I would love
nothing more than to walk out of my Hut
into a field of fresh fruit and and farm
them and smile upon a grateful Universe
knowing that we have snapped out of
existence the corporate press and the
establishment garbage manipulative trash
I want to see the Liars called out I
want to see accountability from The
Establishment the daily wire is doing
that good for them we want to do that
too that's what I want to do every
single day so when I see the daily wire
pulling this off and I see CNN failing I
know that we are we are we are winning
it's a big turn in the time man that's a
that's a well like a extremely
established turn in the in the momentum
of if you want to call culture War like
the sense of the I mean
they've they've not only have they
increased their subscriber Base by like
20 30 in like three months which was
massive what was it 600 000 to 900
something yeah that's a 50 increase yeah
yeah it's this is really really well
that's from one documentary that's from
Matt's I am mostly as a woman that's a
big part of what that came from I think
Gina Carano of course the the terror on
the Prairie came out Gina's just a
superstar right now I mean she's a big
part of the momentum of that and
deserves she's notoriety as she's
getting let's just do some math real
quick
twelve dollars per month
300 000 people
per month
it's like 1.7 million one
no it's it's it's 3.6 3.6 million per
month per month added on top of their
existing 600 000 so they're they're
hitting like I think I think the math is
10.6 million dollars per month
per month that's just in subscriptions
and that's not counting their ad Revenue
yeah man merchandise all that stuff we
got to get 300 employees 890
000 website you know but you know it's a
snowball rolling down hill they've been
doing this for seven eight years now
right so they're really really taking
off and uh man it just feels good man
you know sitting back and just seeing
their success it was really funny
because when the news broke I tweeted
out saying holy-ish and then I have
these Lefty journalists saying like haha
LOL and laughing and I'm just like bro
you're like I'm the verge of being
unemployed what are you laughing about
you're gonna go you're gonna go manage
an AMC like
what are you doing I got question now is
is Jordan an American citizen is he
going to get his American citizenship
after this like he's no he's Canadian I
don't know moving to Tennessee is he
going to go to Nashville he's probably
gonna or is he just keeping on with
keeping on I don't know I don't think he
has to be an American citizen do a
contract with no but does he get to
become one now I know he's fed up with
the Canadian government I mean he said
some really really he's want to just
introduce probably most accurate
harshest critics and justifiably so I
don't know if you know this but I'm
pretty sure you can just buy citizenship
like if you're rich at that point yeah
at that point and then you reach a
certain point where it makes sense to
renounce your citizenship for tax
purposes so I'm not sure where he falls
in that Spectrum on whether it makes
sense for him to become a citizen or to
renounce it well our Canadian taxes
higher or lower than the US
the income tax well now with the
increase
um I think our taxes might be higher I
think that at the higher level the
income tax is higher where Canada gets
you isn't necessarily the income tax
being hired in fact they're corporate
tax uh for the larger corporations is
lower a lot of American companies like
Burger King was a famous one that moved
to being a Canadian company for the
income for the corporate tax purpose
it's the property taxes and the sales
taxes it's the it's the middle class
that they're hitting with the real taxes
it's the rich aren't the ones getting it
also the censorship tax
which as is unquantifiable I I it's like
I like uh Einstein fleeing Nazi Germany
before it got bad like he saw the
writing on the wall I was like yo well I
mean they've already I'm out they've
also had the not allowed to leave your
Province unless you're vaccinated tax
that they finally uh lifted earlier this
month so um I mean there's there's I
mean if you're talking about overall
burden then uh it goes beyond property
taxes I saw a picture from Canadian
Airport and they were like there's like
four hour Waits or six hour Waits at the
airport and it's just bags every this
huge line what are they what is he
putting in there it's all Trudeau's
fault what he's putting these people
through no I I I I just don't believe
these people are happy
I just can't imagine they're happy
living in Canada
all the Canadian people I know are like
trying to come to America
I'm not even kidding though no and then
it was funny I was hanging out some
Canadian friends and I was ragging on
Canada and they were getting really mad
they were like you Americans are so
arrogant and I'm like you're trying so
hard to come here dude and they're like
that's still Americans are so arrogant
I'm like yeah and you want to be here
dude yeah
I agree that American arrogance was
grotesque because we really need to live
the ideals of the Constitution you know
it's not just it's not fair to like rest
on our Laurels because they work so hard
and intelligently to build that awesome
document and yeah I don't know I think
this country is going to implode like we
I didn't want to lead with the story but
I was talking about the dod earlier
saying they're going to keep performing
abortions regardless of whether the
states banned them right and I'm like
what happens if a woman
let's say you've got an active service
Personnel who lives in Texas where
they've just banned abortion
and she goes to a military base to get
an abortion and they have a civilian
doctor Contracting on the military base
to perform abortions yeah
I'm pretty sure I don't know about Texas
but I know there are laws that say that
if if you leave to pursue an abortion or
Aid in a bet someone getting an abortion
you can be criminally charged so I kind
of I'm feeling like in Texas
if if you live in the state then go to
Federal jurisdiction the federal
government's like don't worry you can't
be prosecuted for what we do here it's
legal when you come back they'll be like
no we have a law that says it doesn't
matter where you go to do it it's
illegal so I think about stuff like that
and I'm like yeah I think the US is kind
of about to explode you know but but you
know I say that just to provide a little
like juxtaposition to this good news
about the culture War because I don't
think it it means that the end is nigh
it just means we're in for a conflict a
revolution or something something what I
mean from the libertarian take what
we're hoping for is to move towards
peaceful decentralization and the first
step in that is and this is something
I'm working on on with you or the power
is local County and state level
nullification of bad laws higher up the
food chain that they don't like like the
NFA like the NFA uh you know Missouri
became a second amendment Sanctuary
State and I think New Hampshire just did
uh yes and what the ATF has already said
um and uh border patrol had to say this
with the immigration Sanctuary States
and I mean we know that they've had to
do this with all the Cannabis Sanctuary
states that without the local
authorities doing the like over 90 of
the heavy lifting and the actual
enforcement of these laws it's
functionally impossible for them to be
able to do it love to see it good that's
good well California started it
they wanted to do all the immigration
stuff and now we're going to see all the
two ways and the Cannabis stuff and the
immigration immigration and cannabis
okay great well now we're doing it for
everything that's right and and the
beauty of that is not just the the real
world implications of being able to
nullify bad state and federal policy at
the local level it also empowers the
citizen to know that their vote isn't
just cast into the into The Ether they
can take over their City their County
and eventually their state and get rid
of all the garbage that they don't have
to wear with all the stop at Capitol
Hill they can just stop it from being
effectively enforced where they live
where we are right now in Maryland there
are I think I think it's Three Counties
signed letters saying they wanted to
secede from Maryland to join West
Virginia it's never going to happen but
the county we're in actually declared a
two-way sanctuary
it doesn't mean a whole lot because the
state didn't yeah and so you still got
to get clearance from the state police
to make sure because the laws make no
sense here for guns but up in New
Hampshire the governor just signed a
bill that said they're no longer going
to cooperate with the feds and people
don't understand the feds don't have the
ability to police that country it's not
even close the states have to do it for
them so the the interesting thing is
when I'm reading about what was
happening with um
the the dod basically saying like we're
going to keep doing abortions regardless
of what the state law is I'm like
can federal agents be arrested for
breaking state laws do you know the
answer to that question uh I mean the
states can certainly arrest them for it
uh it's then going to have to work its
way through adjudication to see if
that's upheld the simple answer is well
obviously of course right if if an FBI
agent agent is caught like robbing a
bank yep it's of course of course it's
going to get charged but what I mean is
if in their duties as Federal officers
they break State law can the state
arrest them I think you have a duty to
do it because I mean the Union as it
stands is just a contract amongst the
states the only thing the only reason
the federal government even exists is
because we're letting it exist per our
contract with the Constitution well they
they say that Federal so this is
interesting thing they say it's a
supremacy clause things like that the
federal government's laws supersede the
state so if California says weeds legal
and the FEDS say no it's not the feds
can go into California and enforce their
law but what about the inverse what if
the feds say
a cop carrying a high-capacity magazine
as it's defined by space blue States
they say no no police aren't allowed to
carry those either now and the FEDS go
in with Glock 17s can the state say I
don't care who you are I don't care what
you're doing you broke the law I think
you that's what I can't find I think you
predicted the next one of the next big
uh contentious things to be handled at
the at the federal court level because
um that is likely to happen as the the
um the gap between what the federal
government's priorities and rules are
and what the states are priorities and
rules are that's going to lead the
conflict and it's not happening in
Washington DC it's not happening on
Federal Land it's happening on state
property on on in in state jurisdictions
that's who's likely to get arrested we
know the feds will arrest someone at the
state level uh you know in a Texas
second let me let me actually let's
let's pull the story up and dive anyway
there's some NBC News Pentagon says
Supreme Court's Roe ruling won't affect
abortions on Military facilities right
the military will continue providing
abortions in cases of rape or incest or
when the mother's life is at risk a top
Pentagon official said okay
Texas does not allow those exceptions
rape and insist only the health of the
mother right the life of the mother
so my question is
let's say you you have a civilian doctor
and a female Army you know Personnel
yeah
they she lives off base she's married
civilian doctor does not live on base
but he contracts the hospital on base or
not even that he doesn't need to be
silly let's say he's uh he's he's active
duty military as well lives off base
they both under the jurisdiction living
under the jurisdiction of Texas are
subject to its laws and rules if you are
in the Army and you break the law you
face military court and civilian Court
you get trouble two times yep
so we know they have to obey the laws
obviously you can't have a person to be
like I'm in the military so I can do
what I want so they go into the military
base she gets an abortion the doctor
performs it there is now a record of
that having occurred and the US
government has said you cannot be
criminally charged or penalized civilly
for having this procedure regardless of
the state law right but some of these
states have actually uh I don't know if
they've passed them yet they say if you
Aid and abet an abortion you're guilty
of a crime so that means the doctor and
the woman regardless of where it's
performed coming back into that state
could be arrested because they have
committed the crime according to that
state right what happens if the state
then says we don't care what the FED
said and they arrest this contractor or
to active duty military in the military
is like you can't arrest them it's not
illegal and they say it is here yeah
what happens when states start arresting
military personnel well I think there
are three things there one is the what
happens when the state start arresting
them the second part is is a law that
says you can't do something effectively
somewhere else somewhere outside of our
jurisdiction is that going going to be
able to hold up in court and then also
the question of specific to this uh what
if the feds just stopped recording it
what if the fed's just it's you know no
questions asked abortions being
performed and they just don't you know
one more for you okay woman's in the
military
she is married
they get pregnant
the man says I really think we should
have this kid and she says I don't yeah
and he says I refuse to allow the
abortion happen I think it's wrong I
think it's murder and she says too bad
he knows where she goes he knows who
does it and reports it to the local
state to the state police
you know maybe they're not married
because I don't know if a husband would
do that but let's say there's like oh
she hooks up with a guy yeah whatever
and the guys is like I refuse to allow
you to get a board an abortion I reject
this so he reports her it doesn't matter
if the feds are tracking or not if you
know that you have a witness come out
and then the feds take the active duty
person and say we're going to
interrogate you for as part of our
investigation and she says yes I did it
and it was legal it was on federal
jurisdiction and they say okay stand up
hands behind your back you're under
arrest you write your main silence
you're like what how's this happening
and they say the law states if you ate
in about an abortion and go somewhere it
doesn't matter where it took place I
don't know if Texas has that ruling but
the general idea I suppose is it's not
necessarily the same thing as I think it
might have been like Iowa or Idaho where
they said if you ate in a bet
but if this military base is in Texas
Tech the feds might be like it happened
on federal jurisdiction Texas might
still say you're still in Texas you
still live under our laws
and regardless of that let's just say
letter of the law no no no they can't do
that right okay well according to James
Buchanan States weren't legally allowed
to secede either didn't stop them right
so what happens if you get a Christian
conservative prosecutor in Texas who
says we have made it illegal to kill
babies and then you went into a military
base and killed a baby I'm gonna I'm
gonna charge you and I'm gonna bring I'm
gonna take it all the way to the top
because I believe it's the right thing
to do it doesn't matter what the federal
government thinks they're protected on
and then what the feds are going to be
like trying to pull their people out of
the jail filing lawsuits does it end an
illegal battle or does it end with the
state police surrounding federal law
enforcement vehicles at gunpoint and
saying you're under arrest what happens
then if a federal agent tries getting
the woman out even though she's a known
fugitive of state law is it possible
Texas then says you've ate an embedded a
fugitive I don't care if you're doing it
the feds have no authority to support to
to undermine our laws think about it
this way let's say a federal agent let's
say a female member of the army murders
a kid hits him with a car
and it was on duty driving a military
vehicle and the kid dies and the state
says you are driving recklessly we have
a witness you're under arrest and then
the military says no she was on she was
active duty it was an accident we reject
those charges what happens oh there I
mean that's obvious right like if it's
this if it's on you know in the
jurisdiction of the state where this
gets Mucky would be if she did it on a
military base and the military said
we're handling it and the state said no
it's in our jurisdiction my
understanding of that is that that
wouldn't be their jurisdiction all right
let's try this but we could also talk
about there could be a prosecutor who
says you know reality of power
stop me right the court said I can't do
it the Supreme Court said I can't do it
I'm doing it Anyway come and stop me
here oh so so just throwing
hypotheticals out there I'm not saying
anything any of these are like highly
probable uh pizza delivery guy he drives
on a base and they're like what are you
here for and he's like I gotta deliver a
pizza to base housing and they're like
all right we're gonna search your
vehicle and then you're cool and then
he's driving in and then while on duty
as an MP she crashes into him flips him
over killing him and she was she was not
paying attention and she made an illegal
Lane change and the military says we're
not Prosecuting this we think it was an
accident and then the family of the of
the driver says he's a civilian who's in
our state we reject this we want him
charged yeah yeah I think it's highly
likely in most circumstances in that
case they'd be like it happened on a
military base the feds are gonna have to
him yeah I was gonna say I believe that
that's there's already some
long-standing precedent um both uh I'm
not even sure if I had to be judicial I
think that's understanding that on
Military Base that is federal land
that's not that's not State jurisdiction
so where the question arises then where
this starts to become more akin to the
Civil War is
women going to Federal military going to
military bases when they're not active
duty to get abortions the state knows
they're doing it yeah does the state say
to the federal government
stop breaking our laws or else and the
FEDS say it's our military base you
can't do anything about it and they say
we will send in State Police to arrest
these women the moment they step foot
out there getting arrested because you
are like
if people start going on a military
basis they say and again I know this is
a bit of a stretch they're going to be
providing abortions I think it's
typically only done for military
personnel on military bases but there
are people on the left arguing for
effectively making them sanctuaries for
right exactly yeah
um so my suggestion is is this direction
the direction we may be going oh very
much I mean you want to talk about a
culture War uh there is a gap between
those who see this as you know a woman
exerting uh autonomy over her body
against a clump of cells uh a parasite
and other people are saying No this is a
murder of a baby every bit as much as if
if the woman were to turn around and
murder someone standing next to him and
and there's it's hard to have a
compromise between that right and so if
this plays out and and both sides are
willing to go to the trenches over it
this could lead to what we're talking
about or even worse on just even this
specific subject you made a good point
reality of power that they can say
whatever they want it doesn't matter and
who's willing to do something about it
and so I suppose the issue is let's take
take the moral issue of today with you
with abortion and and go back in time to
slavery so let's say in the north they
said we've abolished slavery and then
let's say it's let's say it's in uh
Pennsylvania
and so it's right on the border of
Maryland which was a slave state and
then you have a military base there that
has slaves and they're like we don't
care that you abolish this we're keeping
we're just going to do it anyway John
Brown would uh probably lose it over
that right the Abolitionist would be
like don't know don't care yeah you
can't do this it's wrong yep so that
that what I fear is
it's just crazy to me that Texas would
come out so strong no exceptions for
rape or incest and the military says we
will like we're getting to that point
where
you just need to imagine it this way if
abortion is murder at least in the eyes
of the Christian conservatives what
they're basically saying is we will keep
killing children and you can't stop us
right yeah at a certain point law
enforcement's going to be like we have
codified this in our law that you cannot
do this and you are doing it yeah well
it's not murder I don't care what what
people believe it's not murder
let's keep that in mind why is it not
it's not illegal in Texas it is well in
certain places if you do it in the wrong
spot you might consider it a murder I
don't know if there is are you saying
from a legal standpoint legal standpoint
murder's a legal term it's killing it's
it's definitely a form of homicide I
mean it depends on if you consider the
level of cells a human rights
is illegal in Texas it is the unlawful
killing of a person in Texas it's
literally is it a person from inception
did they codify that all I know is that
abortions are illegal in Texas yeah I
don't I don't think that I don't think
they've they've codified it as murder
they've just as a as a criminal action
okay um but I don't yeah because
otherwise it would be uh it wouldn't
just be going after providers it would
be if you have an abortion if you're a
pregnant woman that has an abortion you
can face the death penalty for example I
mean that that would be the level that
would be yeah if the pro-life movement
took it to the place where they were
killing mothers or for having a horse
but but you you know you talk to Sheamus
even he's very pro-life he wants a
national band and even he doesn't want
to go there right he's he visit more as
the doctors shouldn't be allowed to
perform these things he's not going to
penalize the mothers who are you know in
the in these positions or whatever
what makes me really bothers me is the
idea that a state would would prosecute
someone for something they did outside
of the jurisdiction I don't understand
that bothers me the most out of all of
this and I mean we could talk about my
concerns about uh how a war on abortion
is just as successful as the War on
Drugs were on terror war on poverty
everything else what happens when you
get government involved as a regulatory
body on something like pregnancy uh and
the harm that comes from that but the
just inside of this the biggest thing
I'm concerned of on a broader scale is
the idea of oh you did that over there
yeah no don't ever come back or we'll
arrest you like that I mean take that to
its logical conclusion it doesn't sound
are there any other instances in the
United States I don't believe that would
be held up there may be some some rule
but as far as I can think I I can't
think of an instance where
um going because I mean you think you
take that to its logical conclusion it's
not just within the U.S that could mean
someone that goes to uh you know the the
Netherlands and tries uh you know uh
ketamine or tries cannabis or something
and then comes back to a state where
it's illegal gets arrested because they
put it on social media that they did it
and then you could even get more obscure
with things that like violate a bylaw in
your county but they they don't violate
a bylaw where you were the the
enforcement mechanism there would be
horrific and yeah it needs to be if if
there's going to be a semblance of rule
of law it's the jurisdiction you are
under those are the rules that you are
under not not the crimes you committed
and then come back or the the things you
did there that were perfectly fine and
legal but then you come back home or or
wherever you reside and now it's it's
illegal there so now you're going to be
charged for a crime I mean imagine hard
enough to figure out what's illegal in a
given place where you are to try to
figure out what's illegal any place you
would then go after that yeah that I I
can't see that being held up then that
would be a major problem and like and
like Tim said we don't even know if
Texas has that but there are other
states that have tried implementing that
for abortion and some of these other
things and it's politicians honestly
virtue signaling to their base not only
can't they do it here they can't do it
anywhere well that's probably not going
to be held up and would you want that to
be held up like would you want the
government to tell you what you can and
can't do when you aren't even in under
their jurisdiction I certainly wouldn't
no no not at all Ian I know you said
um abortion is not murder uh from the
legal standpoint of the word but then
what do you make of uh
murdering a pregnant woman being
considered a double homicide oh it's
homicide it's just not murder homicide
is the killing of a human murder is the
illegal I don't know what's they're
different definitions so like murder is
a form of homicide okay right I don't
know if abortion Bans are considering
abortion homicide though they're not in
Louisiana I think they tried to codify
that and then I got bumped right now no
one wants to do that because I touch
that yeah Mary's point was in um I think
I think Scott Peterson I think Sheamus
brought that up I don't know if it's
Peterson case yes yeah when he got
charged with double homicide because he
killed Lacey Peterson and their unborn
child right so there are jurisdictions
where if a woman is pregnant you punch
her in the stomach you can get charged
with murder yeah actual murder yeah yeah
yeah actual like it's the the mother or
manslaughter kill the baby she
miscarries yeah yeah okay well you you
um just to clarify you can get charged
with murdering the baby if you punch her
in the gut right murder manslaughter it
depends on I believe it's state by state
because I know in California and a lot
of people thought how ironic like
California which is you know when it
comes to abortion the most uh you know
liberal on that subject uh but when
Scott Peterson killed Lacey Peterson and
her child
he was charged with double homicide with
double murder very strange for
California
they're like no no no he he did kill her
but the rest was a clump of sales it
comes down to the argument that well it
all depends on the mother's intent
because she wanted to keep The Unborn
Child no I didn't say it made sense
age of the will where your will equates
to the to the truth of the matter yeah
no if it comes down to if if a state
because really it comes down to
personhood right like if a state has
decided that personhood doesn't begin
until birth or some point after
conception and this uh fetus unborn
child whatever you want to call it uh
hasn't reached that point of personhood
yet well then that would mean whether it
was through an abortion or through
someone killing the the mother or
attacking the mother and the the fetus
unborn person dies you would have to it
would either always be
uh homicide or or a crime or it would
always not be that because that thing
doesn't have personhood yeah I would
think there it's a there's a value to
the intricacy of of killing an unborn
fetus that maybe isn't considered a
person that's that's different than just
destroying a Cell Block but also maybe
not as horrific as like a murder charge
yeah yeah it's some kind of a crime was
committed but not necessarily murder if
you're if you're going the route of
saying that it doesn't have personhood
yet check us out I just I just Google
searched this The Unborn victims of
violence act yes is the United States
law that recognizes an embryo or fetus
in utero as a legal victim if they are
injured or killed during the commission
of any of over 60 listed federal crimes
of violence the law defines Child In
Utero as a member of the species of homo
sapiens at any stage of development the
law is codified into codified in two
sections of U.S code blah blah blah the
law applies only to certain offenses
over which the US government has
jurisdiction including certain crimes
committed on federal properties against
certain federal officials and employees
and by members of the military in
addition it covers certain crimes that
are defined by Statute as Federal
offenses wherever they occur so look to
put it simply if you kill an unborn baby
since 2004 it has been considered a
crime and the embryo is a legal victim a
person too according to what you were
saying what's the name of that again The
Unborn victims of violence act yeah that
was the Bush Administration and uh the
GOP congress's kind of foot in the door
of normalizing the idea of like you know
this is an unborn child it's it's also a
victim for future references you know
and this is also why abortion should be
banned or restricted or whatever so this
was Bush's way of of virtue of signaling
that The Unborn fetus is a is a person
not just signaling but actually creating
the the legal mechanism to to build upon
in the future the camel's nose Under the
Tent and you know a few years later you
got a full camel in your tent
um the
um uh the the purpose behind that as Tim
noted that's for federal offenses or for
federal Personnel like military
personnel or whatever so like if it's
outside of federal jurisdiction that
doesn't apply so the whole purpose of
that even though it's very limited when
it could ever be used the whole purpose
of that yes was to signal to the base
but also to create that that
infrastructure or that legal mechanism
to make future uh build upons in the
field this would mean that in Washington
DC for instance if you commit one of
these listed crimes against a pregnant
woman resulting in the death of the of
the of the fetus then you're you're
charged with this yeah exactly but I
guess I guess what is the charge is it
uh feticide is it homicide is it murder
manslaughter how do they how do they
handle it uh that I don't know I guess
if it's a legal victim and considered a
person it would just be homicide
or whatever they did to it like
basically whatever you did to the to the
the fetus right um they call it murder
had you done it to a you know a
post-born person whatever
um it's the same problem the title of
the bill is an act to amend Title 18 U.S
code and the uniform code of military
Justice to protect unborn children from
assault and murder and for other
purposes yeah so quite literally they
refer to it as murder yeah if it was
killed it would be murdered or whatever
abortion's not part of this it's an
exception it's abortion but I could
imagine this argument happening where
they're like well abortion should be uh
considered part of The Unborn victims of
violence act so we got to be real
careful that they don't start
interweaving these without people
understanding what's happening because
if a mother goes in for an abortion and
then gets charged with murder because of
some stupid law that's gonna just
unravel the the fabric of society we've
got to not start punishing women for
this is I believe a gray area right now
because the the Roe v Wade decision uh
they decided they say sidestep the
question of is this a ninth amendment
issue where abortion is an unenumerated
right or is it a 10th Amendment issue
where this was never covered under the
Constitution and therefore it should be
left to the states of the people instead
they sidestepped and said well it's
really it's a question of privacy it's a
violation of privacy
um and so in overturning this uh the the
uh the current Supreme Court said not
only it's not a ninth it's not a privacy
issue they said it's also not a ninth
amendment issue but they said it's a
10th Amendment issue meaning it should
be left to the states so at least as it
was decided it did not sound like they
had an appetite for a federal ban on
abortion the fascinating thing to me in
all of this there was a tweet from a
personality I saw on Twitter who uh was
was wondering why he said something like
name any medical procedure where you
have no right to privacy
why isn't this a theme of blah like and
I was like did you read row
because I don't think any of these
people actually know what the point of
Roe was or the decision one of which uh
was stated by the Supreme Court the
fetus itself is a living being with a
right to privacy therefore the question
of an abortion is not about a single
person but about two persons which is
why we ended up with the trimester
um ruling was like basically they said
okay in the first trimester you can get
an abortion but afterwards now you have
to consider the person's life which is
the baby and then with Casey they said
it's a viability it's not trimester yeah
I don't think any of these people
realize that they keep saying things
like my body my choice and you're like
read row they're specifically saying at
a certain point you have to recognize
there are two bodies here yeah they
don't even they don't even recognize
that in the federal law they actually
have a photo here on the Wikipedia page
of a woman named Tracy Marciniak holding
the body of her son she was seriously
injured in an assault during the nine
month of her pregnant ninth month of her
pregnancy so that that that's what I
often say like I don't understand why
there is a legal distinction
between two babies of the exact same
amount of time since conception but one
has been removed from the womb and one
hasn't why why is there a legal
protection for one but not the other I
don't understand any logical or moral
statement
mostly because the woman still has the
protection the protections like deferred
to the mother if the baby's in the womb
but I that that still doesn't fly like
if a mother was
shielding her baby from your assault and
you ended up hurting her hands and
killing the baby you still committed
homicide well like if you if a pregnant
woman goes and kills someone you don't
charge the baby with accomplice to
murder no because but it's the second
person that was there you know and doing
going through all the Motions with them
like it's an argument that you don't the
baby's not not able I'm not following
the Babel the baby's not able to make
choices at that stage so you can't treat
it like why would you like kidnapping
someone while you commit crimes we don't
say the the kidnap victim is responsible
for the crime yeah so there's bringing
your child to a bank robbery we don't
hold the child responsible they're
occupying the same physical space
there's two parallel debates here one is
the personhood debate you know when it
does this cease to be a clump of cells
and when does it become a full-fledged
person that has the same legal and and
moral and ethical protections that
anyone else would have a secondary
debate is even if it has Hood at some
point before birth which I think I I
it's hard to argue that it like there's
some Magic Moment passing through the
womb like oh now it's magically a person
uh but the the secondary debate there
becomes you know at what point if ever
does one human life have the right to
the you know connection to another human
life for its uh subsistence and so that
that has been an argument that you know
the mother and that's why it comes down
to what the mother wanted or or intended
or decided is the idea well that the
mother uh shouldn't have to be you know
should the mother have to be uh you know
tied to and be providing uh you know
subsistence to and risking uh you know
her life and health for a second person
even if it is an actual you know
recognized person that does that does
that go ahead oh no I was gonna say this
work it's interesting because if you
look at polling across the board over
the past several decades most people
you'll see the left will be like 80 of
people so are pro-choice and I'm like
yeah but they also really resent and
reject elective abortion because the
average person when you're asking about
abortion they think they imagine this
woman who's crying and being like I have
no choice you know I need to make the
right decision for my life and my family
and I wish it wasn't this way but
instead you have like 93 of abortions
are elective no reason given many women
use it as a form of contraception most
people don't like that so when you look
at I actually went through tons of data
yeah all these different polls all these
different institutions because I'm like
okay they're saying I can't believe that
most people in this country are just
like totally fine with abortionist
contraception and people keep saying
they do and it's like when you actually
look at the questions asked you realize
actually they're not okay with elective
abortion and they're very much in line
with I think how Oklahoma's been
handling it meaning abortion is legal in
any legitimate circumstance legitimate
being a very very narrow band of
acceptable causes for why abortion can
happen yeah and most people I think it's
more than two-thirds around 70 say
abortion should only happen with a
legitimate reason and I'm like that's
actually very restrictive that would get
rid of 93 of abortions
you're not hearing that when it comes to
what the left is actually arguing when
they're talking about this so I bring
that up because you mentioned the um
the uh woman is providing her body yeah
yeah to the child and this is an
important distinction in the issue of
rape and incest I actually I think you
have a very very difficult position
but in this instance especially I think
women have a right to abortion
particularly because
if you're gonna make the argument that
women made irresponsible choices and
then got pregnant rape's not an
irresponsible choice right it's a
victimhood yeah and so here's the
challenge because because I've argued
with this with Sheamus
if a woman says I'm gonna go party
tonight I don't need protection and then
gets pregnant
then someone makes the point the
government can't mandate she provide her
body to another being it's like well
hold on she made the choice to provide
her body to that being and now wants to
rescind it yeah it's not that she made
the choice specifically thinking it
would happen but she engaged in the
behavior which results in that it
happened and now theirs are being
dependent upon her so it's it's like
if you agree to uh a medical procedure
that would provide a direct link to
another person's blood and then after
two weeks said I want to shut this down
they'd be like well now you'd be killing
the person it's a different story as
opposed to someone forcefully jammed you
know you've fused your body with someone
else Human Centipede style right then
I'd be like you had no right to do that
and you can't hold it again but the
incest thing isn't a victimhood either
an uh incestors consensual disagree well
there could be rape involved in a in an
incest situation but if if a brother and
sister decide to have a baby together I
don't understand how that would be
different than having like a child with
some sort of deformity in the womb I I I
I do understand your point and I think
there is an important moral distinction
to be made that individuals can choose
to engage in that behavior but I also
think incest has a special a special
space in that it results in serious
problems it can in inbreeding they would
call it but like the soaking like that's
why it's illegal just actually yeah yeah
but so can any any kind of deform like
if you find out it not at three weeks or
seven weeks that the child has like a
brain deformity or something then it's
it's basically like an ins like a like
an incest gone wrong right but also I
mean when they say the reason they say
rape and incest is very often incest is
rape it is rape within the family like
the power dynamics alone of you know a
father having sex with it and
impregnating a daughter that's rape like
I mean there's you know that's not it
would be very hard to argue especially
if you got a very young daughter or
something like that statutory rape yeah
well not just statutory but also from
the standpoint of like this is a child
like it's it's pedophilia or hemophilia
or whatever you want to call it so it's
it is also an act of of sexual assault
or rape uh in addition to the fact that
they're related so so uh that's because
uh the child can't
consent the idea is legally a child
until they're 18 right consent so it's a
form of rape right if they call it
statutory you're not actual you're
making this thing by like two consenting
adults
siblings that have get pregnant should
they just be able to go get the baby
aborted at five months I mean it's a
good point because
um we certainly are not okay with the
idea of eugenics based abortion where
it's like I don't like the baby has I
I'm told the baby will not be well
therefore get rid of it because if the
incest is the same argument then yeah
but I I want to point something out
because um I saw a meme and it's the
it's the it's the the two arms coming
together with like two distinct ideas
and then coming together over one you
know what I'm talking about yeah and
it's a slavery and abortion and then
together it said denying personhood
rights and I was like Ah that's really
funny because it's Democrats that are
denying personal today and then I was
gonna make a joke I was like you know
who else denied personhood rights and I
was gonna put the Confederates and then
I was like wait those are the Democrats
too it's literally just the Democrats
yeah yeah I want to tell you I mean I
don't know how much longer you wanted to
talk about this so I want to I do want
to get this in I actually personally
consider myself pro-life I think that
abortions are more often than not
gruesome and regrettable things
um the reason that I really do not like
the idea of government getting involved
in this is because if you look at how
government handles things they never
just handle this
they by their very nature there's
Mission creep and they just keep getting
more and more and more involved if they
take the turn of saying this is a
constitutionally protected person inside
of your body and we have to make sure
this person is not killed that doesn't
end there it is also we need to make
sure you're taking care of this person
and if we're making sure you're taking
care of this person we need to make sure
that you're getting regular inspections
and if there's a miscarriage we're going
to have to investigate that and you know
what you're going to need to be taking
uh you know keep your vitamin levels at
a certain level and keep your BMI below
a certain level this inevitably if you
look at the history of how government
ends up regulating things this will
inevitably at some point especially once
the progressives decide that they've
lost this battle and they're just going
to fight it on the other side it will
lead to pregnancy licensing if and if
that sounds insane by the way for anyone
who thinks that sounds insane go back a
hundred years and tell someone all the
things they have to have a license to do
right now and now go forward 10 20 years
and tell someone that you could have an
unlicensed pregnancy and look at the
look of horror on their face and
whenever something has to be licensed or
regulated here come the rent-seeking
crony lobbyists who want to make sure
that their prenatal vitamin is mandated
so now what used to be eight dollars a
month is now 500 a month and who knows
if your insurance is going to cover it
and you're going to end up inevitably in
a situation because abortion illegal
abortions will always be available there
will always be a black market for it
where poor women who are unable to
afford a legal regulated pregnancy end
up getting an un getting an illegal
abortion who would have otherwise kept
the child because they can't afford the
burden of getting illegal pregnancy and
it's way easier to hide an illegal
abortion than a than an illegal notion
in that anyone's miscarriage would be
investigated in the circumstance that
you know
abortion would be federally banned or
but then anyone could just say they
miscarried instead of had an abortion
Roe v Wade was the start of the
government encroaching upon women's
bodies
like that's what do you mean by that
that's the new precedent they shouldn't
have gotten involved in the first place
they're regulating pregnancy and so so
just read that one
U.S women are being jailed for having
miscarriages
now it could be wrong yeah it could be
wrong right they say a 21 year old
Native American woman from Oklahoma was
convicted of manslaughter after having a
miscarriage people were outraged but she
was not alone
they say she was sentenced to four years
in prison for the first degree
manslaughter of her unborn son was she
doing drugs maybe that's what I've seen
a couple cases like this and I was like
what the heck The Examiner did not
determine the cause of death noting
genetic anomaly placenta abruption or
maternal methamphetamine use could have
been contributing factors so it was the
drug use yes but it led to an
investigation and the problem is if
you've criminalized abortion then the
easy loophole if they're not actively
investigating miscarriages is to just
say oopsie got a miscarriage right and
so that can trigger I mean it's not like
every single time they're gonna you know
have someone and they're gonna be
drilling and putting the lights on them
and all of that but at the very least
there has to be some follow-up by law
enforcement to make sure this was a
legitimate uh miscarriage now imagine
being a woman who's just had a
miscarriage I think that that is
inevitable do you think that before 1973
everyone who had a miscarriage was
getting investigated uh no actually
before 1973 and really before the
restrictions that started a few decades
prior her abortion was actually
something that was largely unregulated
in the U.S and so it wasn't really
coming in coming into the late uh 19th
and early 20th century was actually when
you saw the band starting uh I will tell
you I mean if you if you take it to a
logical conclusion because otherwise if
that's not the case then really there is
no effective ban on abortion they can
just all say they miscarry the reason
you might have seen bans on abortion
starting in the early 20th century is
that's when contraception was taking off
but that's a whole other oh yeah yeah no
I mean there's there were reasons for
that but and the only point I'm making
is that we haven't seen this exist long
enough to see The Logical conclusion of
what happens when government gets their
their hooks into something
um you know government tends to screw
things up that's what concerns me about
the Roe v Wade overturn is that now
instead of one government involved in
the regulation there's 50 governments
regulating it I don't know but that's
kind of a good thing I don't know
because I don't want the government
decentralization is better than
centralization in general sometimes you
if you argue you know decentralization
should go to the individual right
ideally so if you're arguing that this
is a woman's rights thing that the
obvious argument is that it goes back to
the individual uh if you're arguing that
there should be some regulation of this
then the argument would be that it
should be handled at the state level I'm
kind of transcending all of that and
saying I really just the idea of
government getting involved in something
like this you know the War on Drugs more
drugs empowering of cartels uh the the
the criminalization of otherwise
peaceful human behavior uh the
militarization of the police no knock
rates all of this came from trying to
regulate the use of a substance and and
if you get them now involved in
pregnancy then I'm just I'm very
concerned where that's going to lead not
not immediately but you know years
decades down the road what that leads to
especially once progressives say hey you
know what screw it we'll just regulate
the hell out of it then I hear you on
government involvement the way I have to
describe it is that people recognize a
problem and say let's do a government
program to fix it yes so you have a
wound on your arm you stop a Band-Aid on
it yeah a few months months later they
say oh that wound is looking festery and
stinky let's put another Band-Aid on it
and they keep stacking up bandages on a
festering gangrenous wound they never
they never solve yeah um but that being
said the problem's cultural it is very
much one of the reasons we didn't have
the issue with abortion pre-1973 that we
do today or would is because a very
different culture
today it's like shout your abortion
abortion at nine months you get an
abortion and you get abortion Lena
Dunham coming out saying she wished she
had one even like she no she didn't but
she she didn't get pregnant she was
saying she wishes she just got pregnant
so she could have an abortion she was
like all these women talk about and I
want to talk about it too and it's like
that's messed up that's a complete Psy
of that anyone would think so I had to
say Psy up that
um you know anyone is favorable to that
I think most people feel rather lukewarm
or have mixed feelings about abortion no
not the zombies dude that like Michelle
wolf did a whole bit where she was like
you get in a bush and yeah and they're
all cheering yeah but the masses not the
Talking Heads oh for sure right right
right right I see what you're saying
yeah yeah regular that's what I was
saying most people and you'll get the
polls are like we think abortion should
only be allowed with legitimate reasons
and like that eliminates 93 that's a
much more nuanced take than either side
wants to say there's there's not there's
not this large plurality that's like
yeah yes even if you've been raped you
have to carry the child nor is this
large necessarily large plurality that's
like yeah all the way up to the very
moment of birth we're cool with it um
but like you said it's a cultural issue
it's also an economic issue like if you
look at the the surveys that have been
done of women that get abortions it's
largely for economic reasons a lot of
them are already mothers who have just
made an economic decision well that's a
problem that can be solved in an
economic thing I I I wish most of it was
no reason given
of reasons that are given economics is
the main one and so the point of that is
that you know I think that I wish that
there was more Focus put on addressing
the concerns and reasons why women get
abortions uh getting rid of some of
these ridiculous uh restrictions on
adoption which by the way pro-lifers
agree with I hate watching pro-choicers
or pro-abortion whatever you want to
call them on Twitter and on Facebook
going well you know if these pro-lifers
really cared they'd want to loosen the
restrictions on adoption well yeah
pro-lifers actually do want that like
they they they definitely want that they
want adoption to be easier it's it's
like what two adopted kids yeah no it's
it's it's they absolutely want that so
that that's a a common point that we
could all agree on let's jump to some
domestic issues we'll get off the
abortion stuff for a bit we got this
story from Jalopnik I love using leftist
sources for this stuff Biden warns
Americans gas prices will remain high as
long as it takes the pre yes right the
president said gas prices will stay high
to combat Putin and Russia's war on
Ukraine
I love it I love it he's basically
saying don't vote for me I think it
sounds like more of a threat than a
warning uh Biden threatens Americans gas
prices will remain high as long as you
take that you want Ukraine to win or not
now pay up yeah yeah it's amazing so at
a time when the Democrats are desperate
to find someone to run in 2024 because
they don't think Joe Biden is going to
make it Joe Biden's giving them all the
reason to try and find someone else to
run in 2024. you know here I I like the
theory that you know there have been
people that have said that he keeps like
giving calls for help that he doesn't
really want to be doing this and that
he's like you know they won't just let
me go eat ice cream and like he'll like
come like at different like candid
moments where he'll be like they told me
to come out here and say this so I guess
I have to say that this might be him
just like you know please like don't
know I don't want to yeah everyone's
gonna have to pay higher gas prices will
you finally just replace me because I go
sit down somewhere yeah this is a
blatant honesty I mean the whole as long
as it takes things is political
propaganda but he's basically
acknowledging that it's not gonna come
back down yeah if you remove as long as
it takes this is an axiom this is as
long as the policies that are in place
are in place the gas prices will remain
High
um and it's crazy because it was I
believe earlier this month that Biden
did correctly acknowledge that right now
the biggest bottleneck at least in the
U.S when it comes to uh uh domestic gas
production is at the refinery level but
then he he blamed the refiners and said
oh you're not producing enough and
you're you're profiting you know you're
price gouging us and then the refiners
came out and said we're at like 96 98
capacity if you right now uh lessen some
of the environmental restrictions of
regulations on us we could increase
capacity by double digits and if at the
same time you allowed us to build some
new refineries for the first time in
decades while simultaneously reducing
some of these tariffs on the materials
that we need to build the refineries we
could short-term fix it with reduction
of regulations and long-term fix it by
building more refineries but you know
he'd rather say hashtag Putin price hike
Joe Biden said when he was campaigning
he's going to transition us off of
fossil fuels imagine hearing him tell
you that voting for him and then coming
out and being like Joe Budden doesn't
control the price of gas yeah like dude
he told you he was going to do this it's
like that Pikachu face meme where it's
like I'm gonna make gas prices go up
okay gas prices go up
how did this happen and and you try and
explain to them all of the reasons some
of which are are BS they're like it's
corporate profits that explains
everything suddenly yeah and I'm like
okay break down for me the corporate
profits thing and they're like what do
you mean like explain to me how much
money they make like I don't know I just
saw a meme on Facebook and I'm like if
inflation is through the roof and the
cost to produce oil has gone up and the
cost to drill for oil has gone up that
means their profits will in increase to
the same percentage point so I'll put it
simply
if you if if you make a hundred dollars
in profit and it cost you seventy five
dollars to produce the oil that's a 25
profit if the costs increase by twenty
five percent and then you increase the
cost of fuel as you sell it by 25 it
will also look like your profits went up
25 but you retained the same level of
buying power these people don't
understand that yeah so sure maybe you
can say but they're still getting lots
of profits that is true they are still
making billions of dollars but it's also
absurd to be like well they should they
should sacrifice their profits for the
sake of Joe Biden's energy policy no no
look I'll be I'll be fair and say yeah
they probably should work alongside with
the government to lower prices but we
still can point out Joe Biden enacted a
bunch of policies specifically to
transition us off of fossil fuels but to
be well and exactly I mean it's he said
that I'm gonna do this and it was like
okay good but now what they didn't
realize is transition isn't like
rainbows and unicorns transition means
make this prohibitively expensive so you
have to do this that's what a transition
that's forced by government looks like
as opposed to a mark driven transition
where it is unicorns where it is look at
this new thing that's way better as
opposed to we're going to make this
thing way worse in comparison you see
these uh these flight cancellations yes
you see other stuff oh I don't just see
it about that I have been the victim of
them yes we've been too like they
abruptly will change someone's ticket
yeah cancel their flight or or change it
right then we have it like they just
move someone's flight to the next day or
something no that was them doing it yeah
yeah they emailed me and they're like oh
yeah he changed that he just didn't oh
okay okay that's fine no but there are
stories in the Press where people are
saying that happened to me yeah that
they just changed your flight to a later
date or something I have gotten on an
airplane gotten a notification that the
flight had been canceled what and then
just start getting up because I realized
they're about to announce it to everyone
else too and they've done that before
yeah and we ended up having to say that
was at Charlotte airport we ended up
having to stay the night there and like
I'm looking at I'm like no we're on the
we're on the plane and I look and the
doors open I'm like I'm like we're
getting off the plane and we did and
sure enough like as I'm getting off the
plane they're like uh everyone we have
an update and I'm like yeah the update
is this flight is canceled see you
tomorrow morning uh they said it was
because of um oh what did they say they
always say maintenance and that's
because of some kind of thing with the
flight insurance they don't have to pay
as much out or something like that but
the reality is uh I talked to one of the
pilots as we were leaving and they're
like yeah we already went over our hours
and they thought that these other Pilots
coming in would be able to do it but
they went over their hours too I talked
to a pilot and he said most Pilots are
hitting their limit yeah and so they're
are just you know so my question though
is how
where did all the pilots go like they
couldn't turn the vaccine mandates they
were like well I'm not getting the job
and they load and vaccine mandates and
we were told the media was like they're
not protesting vaccine mandates
everything's fine yeah a bunch will
probably quit my I like the idea that
everybody got raptured better because it
sounds more fun because we have a good
Pilots
the good Pilots went to heaven were all
in hell yeah I've been thinking about
this because why are there shortages
everywhere where are people why aren't
people working yeah it's not even maybe
it's the vaccine mandates and and that
could be really it that most people just
said I'm out I'm not doing it and now
but but where are those people I mean
they Gotta Eat Right Black Market but
but how what are they doing they got to
make money doing something but they're
still not here so we went out we went to
the movies over labor I think it was
Labor Day and uh there's nobody anywhere
and I'm just like where are the humans
where are the humans so the fun
conspiracy theory it's not really a
conspiracy but the fun joke theory is
that the Rapture happened and um all of
the people that got raptured are our
memories of them was erased so now we're
just sitting here wondering why all of
the stores have Labor shortages why
there's no Pilots anymore they're all
gone and we just can't remember who they
were oh good so I have a new nightmare
thank you for that that's good and then
uh
was like that can't be true you know
because Sheamus is Catholic right he
would have to be Rapture too and I'm
like I don't know
someone found out they were wrong yeah
no but in all seriousness though
something doesn't make sense I think
they're at home collecting unemployment
but first if they're not for this long
not for this they were canceling flights
last year they were yeah you're not
going to be on unemployment for two
years for for I mean we're going on uh
18 months is that the long they did
extend it so there is actually an
explanation for this when you pump
trillions of dollars into the economy
and artificially create demand while
simultaneously paying people to do
nothing you create a bunch of consumers
and reduce the number of producers and
we're watching that play out in real
time the way that corrects is through a
massive recession which is coming if it
hasn't already started it's coming and
it is the reality of when and this by
the way anyone who's still out there
promoting modern monetary Theory or Ubi
or any of that nonsense this was a
couple times of them handing off checks
and expanding unemployment insurance by
a little bit and look at what it led to
it led to such a disruption in the
market that everyone became net
consumers and and stopped Purdue
reducing and the Ripple effects of that
will be felt for years should I take out
a bunch of loans right now is what
you're saying yes you should take out
loans uh credit card debt uh anything
you have a title for go to the title
loan place this is the time to buy
you've got to buy in this is well so the
idea is if the recession's coming and
the value of the dollar is going to tank
then then the buying so like a car
that's worth 20 grand today is going to
be worth 40 Grand in a year yeah you
take out a loan for a twenty thousand
dollar car and in a year you sell it for
40 Grand you pay off the loan you got a
free 20 grand
I mean that's some that's some uh Brave
pool you're playing there but yeah I
mean what I mean is Rich guys game what
rich people do that is what we know that
is what rich people do but except they
do it on your back right they do it with
uh fed money that just got freshly
printed and if everything goes south and
they're too busy this is the point I'm
making right before the recession they
know that if they borrow a hundred
thousand dollars and then the buying
power that hundred thousand dollars
collapses they basically got a freebie
now they can sell whatever they bought
because the price will will Spike yep
the value of the dollar goes down so
you'll need twice as many dollars to buy
it so they'll get the free money yep yep
have to buying power with none of the
work I can imagine that that breaks down
at some point what's the inevitable
conclusion of that Ponzi scheme it just
keeps getting worse that's what that's
what we have right now so like you look
at the difference between the
2007-2008 uh the the
um the housing price bubble that then
crashed and then caused the whole ripple
effect to the recession which then led
to the whole concept of too big to fail
and the tarp bailouts at a zero to that
and that's what we're this is a whole
you know this is an exponential this is
a whole order of magnitude higher of
what we're facing now like we're
literally instead of hundreds of
billions and trillions we're now talking
trillions and tens of trillions and it's
hard to quantify what the Ripple effects
are going to be and they just keep
feeding into it and that's why you see
this this you know they talk about the
uh um the uh yes 40 yes I love this 40
of all the money that has ever been made
has been made in the last two years this
is also savings yeah you can explain
this this spike is when they said your
savings account is now a checking
account so they put Savings in a
circulation okay so uh but look at this
the hockey stick yeah okay that's the
creation of currency and they I think
they did that yeah they were about to
start printing get that upper uh
diagonal that big one that what is it
like a 80 degree angle instead of a 27
90 yeah to make it look less severe yeah
and I'm glad you pointed that out
because this doesn't look like a 40
increase this looks like a 600 increase
but it's right it's the definitional
change that happened thank you for so
what we got to do is get a graph where
we remove the vertical line and just
watch it go from the 27 degree angle to
the 80 degree angle it's still ugly yeah
it's still not good and this is only up
until 2020 like August of 2020. it looks
like what's going on now and what's
what's funny is the uh fractional
Reserve policy changed just before covet
yeah it was like in April 2020 or
something it used to be that you needed
a reserve to lend loan up money and then
they went we're getting rid of that you
can just loan as much as you want yep
yeah zero percent right fractional
Reserve imagine plan a game of Monopoly
and all of us are playing by the rules
okay and every single I'm gonna make you
the bad guy here sorry
um all of us all of us are playing by
the rules right like you know you you
roll your dice you go the number of
things you go to the number of of uh
that you the number of spaces you decide
whether you want to buy hold whatever
and then when it's Mary's turn uh she
goes to the banker and says give me a
trillion Monopoly notes and stick them
all with the bill for it that's our
economy
and the the problem is the price of of
living is going up the same for everyone
but the closer you are to that money
supply at its initial printout at its
initial disbursement the less affected
You Are by the double digit price
inflation and the the more you're
exposed to the triple quadruple digit
increase overnight of your wealth and
that's what we're seeing here here's
another important factor here
um
Bitcoin dropped I think to like 19k or
whatever yep and everyone's screaming in
the media and I'm just like I don't know
I don't care I'm ignoring it and that's
the deal when you have money you don't
care that it went down you're like I
don't know what I'm gonna do with it
anyway yeah and then after a year two
years three years it starts to recover
so when people see the stuff and they
actually need their money and they're
seeing it tank and they're like I can't
ignore that and they're forced to sell
it at garbage rates they become poorer
yeah rich people who are more resilient
to the change in monetary value and
recessions and depressions can ignore it
until the recovery happens and then
retain all that value yeah so the rich
get richer the poor get poorer exactly I
would also like to note that Bitcoin has
crashed down to its 2017 High its
previous all-time high before this last
increase there's an old video I wish
they had kept updating it it's about
seven years old now but it's called
don't buy Bitcoin it crashes and it's
this guy going there was this one time
Bitcoin was worth and I'm making up the
numbers but it's pretty much like this
one time it was worth uh point one uh
sense and then it went up to five cents
and then it crashed all the way down to
two cents and then this other time it
was worth three dollars and 25 cents and
then it went all the way up to 25 and
then it crashed all the way down to 780.
and like he keeps doing this and he goes
and so the moral of the story is don't
buy get rip coin it crashes this is the
the uh the uh cycle of parabolic growth
usually some sideways trading and then a
crash down to higher than the previous
all-time high and now the gaps are
obviously not as wide as they used to be
it's a lot easier for something to go
from a dollar to ten dollars than to go
from twenty thousand to two hundred
thousand right like there's only so much
market cap it can have but the pattern's
still playing out this is not Financial
advice by the way yeah yeah I'm just a
Jew on the internet I'm not a financial
advisor but you but you look at the way
the dollar is going and I don't know how
anybody could have faith in their
paychecks at this point really yeah the
the recession that's headed our way
they're saying there's gonna be rolling
blackouts do you guys see these
reporting this reporting rolling
blackouts food shortages food prices so
it's it's it you know what you know what
I'm really proud of uh in 2020 I started
doing the emergency food sponsorships
yeah and then like Vice made like a hit
piece and they were like haha what a
loser and then I'm like man if you if
you bought that food in 2020 it was I
think like half the cost of what it is
today yeah so you'd be sitting on food
that lasts for 25 years at half the
price you'd be like oh wow it's a good
thing I bought it two years ago it's
we're gonna last 23 more years yeah you
buy it today it's more expensive Jim
Baker has the last left even even if
you just decided to eat it today you got
your food at Half Price yep so it's
crazy because you know I was talking
about this in 2020 2021 food shortages
are coming what happens Putin's price
hike whether or not you believe any of
that stuff the fact is it came there is
there is a shortage of wheat which is
going to it's it's going to be
mind-boggling my but mind-bogglingly
devastating not as much to us
but Lebanon you know Saudi Arabia uh all
these these Middle Eastern countries
turkey these countries that get much of
their grain and food from Russia and
Ukraine they ain't going to be getting
it so what are they going to do they're
going to be very very hungry and very
angry and we are going to be watching
we're going to be sitting there and
we're going to be like huh remember when
we used to watch CNN when they were news
no well let's put it on anyway you'll
turn it on and you'll just see food
rights water and food riots and we'll
have some of that here
during the pandemic remember those lines
of cars for Miles waiting for food
because people didn't have any if you
think it's bad now if you think it was
bad back then right now there's nobody
producing no so not only do we have a
fertilizer shortage which which led to
predictions of a crop yield dropping by
40
diesel potential shortage meaning
Farmers won't even be able to harvest
and if they do it'll be substantially
more expensive to harvest and there will
be substantially less food meaning for
more than one reason the cost of food is
going to Skyrocket yeah it's almost a
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt no I'm
gonna say and then people are gonna are
that's that's when people break down and
go crazy yeah it's almost as if
massively expanding the monetary Supply
and then just handing it out leads to a
massive increase in prices uh because
you have the uh much more money chasing
the same amount of goods and services
and then that same amount of goods and
services actually goes down because
people say I got all this money I don't
need to work and so now you've got the
disruptions from that it's it's a
perfect storm for what we're
experiencing you know what we need
seeing this problem happening yes we
need to like we need to figure out a way
to start over some kind of like like a
reset but a bigger one a great one a
great one great reset yeah like a really
big make resets great again yeah yeah
yeah like a great reset yeah and then
maybe when the people people look people
are going to lose everything they own in
this but we need this great reset yeah
and then after that they may own nothing
but they will be happy you'll be happy
they'll be happy pretty good so it makes
you wonder you said it was great that
you sold me it great honestly but it's
called great that it must be but it
makes you but listen listen it makes you
wonder when they advocate for the great
reset literally like calling it that
yeah and then they Implement these
policies that have just destroyed
everything it's almost like they want it
to happen I'm looking at the M1 money
supply I'm kind of investigating it
right now and it does show up until May
oh I'm seeing it up until May of 2022.
it's at the 80 increase until about
uh April 2022 and then it looks like
it's actually gone down yeah because
yeah that's slightly a little bit Yeah
because the Federal Reserve has started
tightening the the rates they've started
increasing the rates the reason that's
happening that is a consequence of banks
being able to lend money or get lent
money at effectively zero percent once
you factor in for inflation they're
actually getting it at negative interest
rate they can turn around and and put it
out there to us to the consumer at a low
interest rate and just make a bunch of
free money basically it's literal free
money so by raising the race and then
buy property with it right bankrupt
people and then seize their assets
destroy their their lives and walk away
holding the bag because people won't be
able to pay back the interest on their
loans Etc things like oh once everything
crashes absolutely that's all the
foreclosures that happened in 2007
protect people from foreclosures because
I imagine BlackRock and other banks are
going to try and steal people you need
to just stop you need to get first of
all you need to get currency out of the
control of the of the government
government isn't political entity that
tries to implement political goals for
political purposes it should not be in
charge of the money supply because this
is what happens when you have a
political entity in charge of the money
supply they create they implement the
money supply not for the best use of its
consumers because they're a monopoly
they don't care about the consumers or
or the people using it they do it for
their political purposes which in this
case is to try to you know push along a
an economy that they don't want to
correct and making things worse in the
process and paying off the cronies who
sponsored them into office sure but you
have to recognize some people are just
really dumb right oh there's that too
yeah and and because they're so dumb you
need better men to rule over them strong
men strong men strong men for a great
reset why has no one else thought of
this
like it took us coming together to
finally figure out what the problem is
haven't you did you ever don't you
remember that speech from Michael
Bloomberg when he attacks the poor he
said poor people spend money on dumb
things yes so we should tax their money
so we can choose for them what to buy
that's one message if there ever was
right he wanted to tax large drinks
because he said poor people are stupid
and buy big sugary drinks and get fat so
let's put a big tax on it so they can't
afford it anymore so they stop doing it
that works that works so you said get
money out of the governor out of
politics or what I don't know how did
you phrase it right so the government
needs to stop being involved in what
money is because if you if you allow the
market to determine what money is now
instead of having a political entity
manipulating openly manipulating the
monetary supply for political purposes
right and and destroying the wealth and
the well-being of the vast majority of
people that are involved in this instead
now you have competing entities who
because they want to be you know have
their dominant market share have a
vested interest in doing the opposite
they want their money to be deflationary
or at the very least not go not have the
the value go down over time have them
the value of the money increase over
time have the the case use the ability
to use it uh go up over time have it Be
an Effective and better thing this is
what we apply to everything else right
like you don't want to have to buy your
car from the government car company
right why would you want to have to get
your money from the government money
company hold on sorry real quick yeah
you not only would you have to buy your
car from the government but they have a
computer chip in it where every year it
goes 10 miles an hour slower yep and
then you're alive literally I gotta get
a new car gotta gets too slow yeah this
is like planned obsolescence for money
right so this is like Federal Reserve
tactics which is a private company
obviously they're in cahoots with the
Monopoly they're monopolized by the
government but like Congress is supposed
to be in charge of the monetary Supply
according to Congress yeah so it should
be amended like no that's the thing like
yes this is Con and by the way this is
why I don't consider myself a
constitutionalist I think the
Constitution is a useful way for us to
use it defensively to protect our rights
but at any point there are times in the
Constitution where it lays out things
that blatantly uh are bad for us and
violate our rights and this would be an
example of that I don't think that
government should be involved in money
they've proven themselves to be a bad
Steward of it and even if you replace
the Federal Reserve because I understand
what you're saying they're technically a
private entity if you replace the
Federal Reserve uh instead with
yes if you replace the Federal Reserve
instead with just a a a federal bank uh
it's effectively the same thing but just
you know with different steps like you
don't need a federal bank that's what I
just handed but we could uh that's the
bank of Columbus ten dollar bill this
was a bank no a private bank credit
right this is what I'm talking about I
think if it was Congress we'd be able to
audit it or it would be like part of it
being the congress's bank is that the
American The People's Bank is that we
would audit it it would constantly be
all public in theory and could it be
better yeah but you still have a
centrally planned Authority right so why
not instead allow a a market-derived
series of notes or in this case it's
probably going to be more electronic but
but you could also have physical notes
there are plenty of people out there
that don't want the the electronic notes
they want the physical notes but why not
let the market determine what is best
for people because the people who are in
power are friends with those who control
the policy that enrich them and why
would they ever walk away from that's
the correct right they collude well no
because people collude and buy up huge
amounts of stuff and then sell them off
all at once and then they they work the
market and so we need a government to
protect us but that's not what's
happening from the fed and they buy up
houses and then you are a working class
family and you're like it's time to buy
our first house this house is going for
200 Grand and you say I will pay asking
and they go great we'll get back to you
and they call you back and say we got an
offer from you know BlackRock or
whatever that's at 2 40. and you're like
I can't afford that and they're like
well sorry
and that's what keeps happening to
people yeah yeah and the thing is a lot
of what the uh the the crony and at this
point it's sort of like a corporatist
fascist extension of government some of
these companies like BlackRock and and
so forth the reason they're able to do
it is because they get free money that's
underwritten by you and by Future
Generations that haven't even been born
yet you reintroduce and I'm not saying
necessarily this but you reintroduce
having the money being determined at by
the market level they have to play by
the same rules as the rest of us and yes
they're wealthier but they're now going
to have to deal with the same supply and
demand issues they're not going to be
able to just yeah Bitcoin they're not
going to be able to just print out
endless streams of money and have you
pay the bill for it have you pay the
debt for it with the interest and uh you
know and then when everything falls
apart they get bailed out and that's
paid for by more money that got printed
out that whole thing goes away when you
take away the ability for them to just
expand the monetary Supply whenever they
want to to pay off their own right this
is why I like cryptocurrency people this
is why it's frustrating when you get
progressives who are acting like
crypto's a really really bad thing
people's like you just established
you're just you're just chilling out for
the establishment people can literally
the way out people can create infinite
amounts of crypto right now without
regulation absolutely that's endless
inflation just the same
problems only if people value exactly it
comes into this is subjective value
right like I can make a coin Tomorrow
based on the ethereum chain or whatever
I call it Spike coin and I go hey
everyone go get some get some spike coin
and they go great what's your what's
your case use what is your what are you
fulfilling that isn't already being
fulfilled they go Spike coin that's not
gonna work No One's Gonna Want It some
people will get it as a joke but it's
not going to go anywhere it's it's and
on top of that I can I can print a bunch
of cards and I can call them uh Tim
bucks yeah and I can be like this is
paper Tim bucks they're worth so much
money hey and people are going to be
like I don't know if I value what I
value it if you value right now all the
people with the Bitcoin and the ethereum
like they're huge people that own
massive amounts of that stuff would own
the market essentially without any
government oversight and then they would
buy up all the corn and then they would
raise the price of corn 13 times and
then sell it back to the people well
first of all just I mean yeah are there
Bitcoin billionaires absolutely but like
the if you look at like the the
distribution of that wealth for lack of
a better term uh it's far less
centralized than you would see for
example where you have like what is it
less than one percent of the population
that owns 20 30 of everything like
that's certainly not happening and with
if you took all the the crypto Bros out
there
um they're certainly not going to have
anywhere near that same uh Market level
that would that exists in this current
system because they can't because it has
to be a system that reflects the actual
Market demands and supply and demand as
opposed to a political entity a
centrally planned political entity
saying all right well you guys help get
me into office and so you know I'm
paying you off and here's however many
trillion dollars I'm gonna give you a
600 check you stay right there you
should make sure to vote for me and uh
and you know also you're getting the the
debt for this guy uh oh this all fell
apart okay well um we're gonna print out
more money and and bail you out because
you're too big to fail you've got to pay
for this you're definitely not too big
to fail that's the system that's yeah
that's the worst the Federal Reserve
unauditable System is the worst by far
but I think that crypto unregulated by
the people would be as could get as bad
the the reg
there is no utopian system but the
regulation comes in place if suddenly
there's a reason for for there to be
suspicion of how Bitcoin is being used
it's out in the open and people can see
it or if it's not out in the open if
there's some coin that you know you
can't see the back end of it you can't
see the Ledger of it it is centrally
controlled people are going to say why
would I use this when I can use this
that's so much better that's what
happens from the market it's like it's
like using the car analogy if you if if
this car company suddenly is making cars
that are absolute garbage you know it
and you go buy a car somewhere else you
can do this with anything chicken
sandwiches of you know skateboards
whatever it doesn't matter like having
more providers makes it bet makes you
more likely to be able to get a better
value and for them to have an
incentivization of serving you as the
consumer but when you when you bypass
that through Central planning now they
don't have to serve you as the consumer
they only have to serve the political
class that they put in office I mean
that's a much easier thing I'm
interested in getting uh Mary I know
you're an expert on fiscal policy and
fintech so what are your thoughts on all
this
I mean I'm trying to to think of the
right questions to ask but
it's very esoteric a little bit
well with the with the walls like with
crypto wallets it looks like there's a
lot of people that because everyone has
a wallet but it could be one guy that
has 900 000 wallets I mean it
this argument doesn't track look I
couldn't I could buy a bunch of rocks
and then I can go around being like Tim
rocks they're only mine and you can't
get Tim rocks from anybody else so if I
buy a bag of gravel it's true that bag
of gravel is exclusively to me he could
own all that I own them all and then
people are like we want it we want it oh
like we'll give you bread we'll give you
labor and I'm like ah giving out rocks
that's no difference between that and
anything just use Bitcoin as your
example so well Bitcoin is decentralized
I could look I can right I can buy
Bitcoin and then I've actually put money
into the system and then I would not
just want to lose the value of that yeah
so other people can value it because
they know there's a market around it
with real value or people are willing to
buy it at some point farmers are gonna
be like we accept crypto you but great
what kind and they'll they'll choose we
accept Bitcoin we accept ethereum and if
you don't have those two cryptos then
you exchange it for that but the value
of those are going to Skyrocket who owns
them when they decide it's this proof of
stake thing that what they want to move
towards away from proof of work who's
creating tokens is who has the tokens
those are the ones that get to make the
decisions to people that have them yeah
those are the ones that are rich right
now they want to move it to a system
where the rich people get to make the
decision right so what's good right now
what could happen I'm not saying it's
what we have right now is it ass it's
terrible what could happen is that
people build faith in a cryptocurrency
that is centralized and controlled by
Rich powerful people
that doesn't change the fact that the
FED is bad and we should find an
alternate system and crypto is pretty
good yeah so Market derived systems
don't necessarily not allow for the
centralization of wealth but in order to
be able to do that you have to serve the
consumer if it's Market derived and not
centrally planned in order to be able to
grow maintain and expand wealth you have
to be serving the consumer better than
your competitors especially if you want
to expand it if you want to maintain it
you have to at least be doing it as well
as your competitors in a system that
isn't Market derived in a system that is
centrally planned through a centralized
Monopoly of violence such as Government
instead what you have is a system where
I don't have to serve you I just have to
be friends you're the bad guy again I
have to be friends with Mary the
government who I just so happened to
bankroll into office and friend Mary too
who's on the other side other side and
uh and make sure that they're my friends
and that they give me whatever I want so
now instead of having to to do the often
you know mind-numbing labor to make sure
that I am serving you and everyone else
is as best as possible and where the
consumer is King instead all I have to
do is spend a Penance of those resources
just keeping them in office keeping them
fat and happy and then getting them to
give me whatever I want that is
inherently A system that feeds
everything has to feed a great a profit
motive right the profit motive needs to
be fed by serving the consumer instead
of serving a small handful of the ruling
they've got to go to Super Chat so if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and
share the show with your friends head
over to timcast.com we're gonna have
that members only show coming up for you
at 11 PM but we're gonna read what y'all
have to say right now so what we got
here the snack lady Jackie says night
nice to see Tasha's husband on the show
tonight I vote him for VP with Dave
Smith president and Michael Mouse press
secretary we need this to happen are you
are you intending to be a VP uh I doubt
I would run for VP I honestly don't I
don't I don't know if I'm going to be
running uh for anything in the future
and right now and part of the reason I
started you were the powers until we
grow this movement massively we're
really talking about who's the next guy
to get the score of the margin of error
like it doesn't matter until we have a
much larger movement so I'm not I
haven't ruled anything out for the
future I just don't really care until
we've done the movement growing right on
and uh would you kindly smash that like
button let's read more and hit the Bell
don't just subscribe hit the Bell we
want your phone to explode with
notifications every time I've never
actually told people to hit the Bell hit
the Bell does it work hit the Bell
everybody who subscribed or subscribe
and then hit the Bell hit the Bell get
the notifications let it wake you up
East app says Spike keep up the
Relentless trolling of the ATF I do what
I can thank you yeah um do you agree sir
that we should abolish the ATF yes the
ATF is a regulatory it's a federal law
enforcement agency targeting what four
uh
legal things uh Alcohol Tobacco firearms
and explosives it's actually now the
batfe but they went back to being the
ATF because everyone's like what the bat
the bureau the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco
firearms and explosives which should be
like a convenience store I know that's
that's like that's like an old Trope
that's not my joke it's like an old
Trope but it's true it's it's a cliche
because it's true the reality is the
government has no business telling you
that what you can own a firearm or
otherwise
um uh and and you can make the Second
Amendment argument of it says very
clearly the right of the people to keep
and bear arms shall not be infringed you
can also make just the rights argument
of uh if I I have a natural right to
defend myself and you can also make the
reality a power argument which is that
if a small handful of people have the
only effective ability to project
violence effectively no one else has any
say in anything right
all right warwolf says with a bunch of
crab emojis potato man is gone that's
right the Potato Man bailed on us so so
now we're stuck with Mary huh no it
works
in a Catholic yeah yeah no but we also
uh we'll have we'll have Mary here we'll
have uh Brett we'll have Jamie we'll
have a couple people bump uh jumping in
and then Luke's on his way back right
Luke right Luke Brett's here Luke
Brett's here Luke even had a problem
with it when Sheamus was on pop culture
what yeah he was commenting boobs potato
man it was in the chat yeah and um
people on Twitter think they have like a
real beef they're like man these guys
really hate each other I know it's a bit
they're like ribbon no it's not a bit
it's completely serious yeah you don't
understand Sheamus cries after every
show every show that's why he left for
him because Luke was trolling him in the
chat so Shane was like I'm leaving
all right all right
what is this
John Kristen says Sheamus talking of
[ __ ] and tubs Tim and C-Town and Ian
double-handed mopping has has me wonder
about what is happening behind the
scenes oh yeah when Ian in the double
mopping thing yeah yeah double double
mopping feel the momentum you actually
have to pretend like the mops are in
your hands you know the pressure that
you feel the friction Raymond Jesus
Raymond g Maga Stanley Jr says who's
ready for Maga month the left may be
setting our country a a burning but
let's use that fire for barbecues
bonfires and building Community go IRL
ladies and gentlemen tomorrow Begins the
first day of Maga month make America
great again month I have my Twitter
profile picture ready it is the same
face but I got the American flag behind
me and this is not just a month in which
you grill burgers every day or on the
weekends whenever you can it's not just
the month where you get the 4th of July
to fire off fireworks the point of Maga
month is to make America great again you
know that means it means y'all should be
engaging in community building community
service you should be figuring out ways
is you can come together with your
neighbors meet people learn from each
other build those communal bonds to
literally make America great again and
um audit the fed or something like that
yeah some political Buzz thing would
notify the government yeah no you can't
make America great again without
nullifying government and building
Community bonds building the purpose of
America is to nullify unjust government
literal purposes Maga month is not about
Trump it's it's about making America
great again and that means if you go out
and pick up trash you've made America
great again yep if you like Scott
Pressler does if you go out and register
people to vote you are making America
great again it doesn't matter if it's
Trump or DeSantis or whatever the point
is start locally
build community meet your neighbors have
a barbecue invite friends over learn
from each other and build those strong
Community bonds and that makes America
stronger I made I realized that man you
get an American flag make America great
again is it like take it back to where
it was when it was great it's the idea
that you're going to continuously do
something to make it great over and over
and over again and right and also in
doing that you show people that they
don't need a lot of people they aren't
you know socialists or status or
authoritarians or whatever they they
they Veer into those things because they
don't see a viable alternative they're
not shown a viable alternative for how
they can be we all want the same things
we want to be safe we want to be healthy
we want to be happy we want to be
prosperous and if we can show that by
building communal bonds that we can do
those things together voluntarily and
not needing some centrally planned
Authority making some caricature
approximation of it that makes
everything worse we can actually reduce
their power that is in people's heads of
the legitimacy of their bad ideas by
showing them a much better alternative
which is us working together
all right let's read some more we got
Travis boss he says Hey Spike Tim the
libertarian party of Eastern Panhandle
convention is July 16th you and your
friends are cordially invited what day
is the 16th I think I think it's a
Saturday the Saturday sure oh let me
check is that in West Virginia yes oh
yeah I am sorry I didn't pass that on to
you you are in fact invited to speak I
passed it on to Shane I don't know if I
can speak to you but yeah so it's over
in the Eastern Panhandle I also need the
details if you wanted you said the 16th
yeah I will unfortunately be at Freedom
Fest Saturday in Vegas oh Saturdays we
can do Saturday that'd be fun yeah to go
to a Libertarian party we should go you
should definitely go well well let me uh
bring the porcupine whoever brought the
porcupine to the West Virginia
convention bring the porcupine and Tim
will definitely come I don't know I'm
penciling it in actually I only have a
pen but yeah that's permanent we can't
erase that you just penned it in he just
pinned it in pencil that in uh no that
actually does sound fun uh where exactly
is it going to be Eastern Panhandle but
we're basically there yeah so um are
there going to be Wings because if you
got Wings chicken wings chicken wings
bring Wings yeah hit the Bell bring some
eggs some farm fresh eggs for everybody
well I'm not gonna fry eggs
I heard they had plant-based human meat
dude we gotta talk about that maybe on
the after show did you guys so they're
actually this is on Twitter um was it
Maji Nawaz tweeted this out then a vegan
burger made it taste like human meat
received an award in can this is not
interested
we'll talk about that for the members in
the morning can what I I'm not asking I
mean it does kind of sound like
something a Libertarian party might do
be like it's about Freedom if you want
to eat people
it's not real people but you're free if
you want to simulate eating people with
consent simulate crime simulate I don't
know like what if a person consented to
being eaten after they died like the
libertarian party
I don't think that's like a modern the
libertarian party has been in favor of
some weird stuff in the past not that
that's why I'm bringing it up like when
the guy took his pants off or when they
booed some guy I mean there's taking
your pants off and there's you can eat
me after I die and I I feel like well
there's also did they didn't they some
guy say uh didn't someone say they
shouldn't sell drugs to children they
got booed
all right all right let's read some more
DC says Ian it's a big leap to call
Christianity a cult but your point about
targeting the individual over the group
is spot on thanks man I I was we were
talking about it before the show I I
think all religions are cults
um it's not an insult it's just an
observation
but then like all belief structures are
Cults regardless I don't know about that
it's the organization of religions that
make them Cults is it bad to be a cult
not necessarily but you just got to
identify the cult behaviors like some
believing things that aren't real yeah
like there's there's impermeable
magnetic field that allows us to
communicate and commune with the
universe
if I had people sit around me and repeat
after me and say it then yeah that would
be very cool I mean any You could argue
if you go that far that anything that
has presuppositional beliefs that cannot
be challenged is a cult and and like the
there are five lights for instance
Picard knows there's four but they're
like just say that there are five even
though we know that you know it's not
real we want you to say it out loud to
acknowledge that you're one of us and I
feel like going to a church and having
them having you repeat stuff like no
one's this bread is actually a physical
is his human body or a woman wasn't
impregnated by a ghost thing is like
it's not right in front of you but when
you have a piece of bread in front of
you and you're made to say that it's a
guy's body you're not made to well they
ask you to repeat it and you can walk
out you can or you can become one of
them if you want to and if you want to
become Catholic whereas Picard was
tortured and electrocuted that's a
different story in the 1500s you would
get tortured for not not today though
all right let's see let's read some more
waffle Sensei says the Beloved and
empirical Elon will just reinstate
Jordan Peterson why would he cave now
and it's basically guaranteed he'll be
back on yeah I think that that's the
long game yeah October I think is what
they're saying yeah the deal should be
closed by October yeah I don't know for
sure though that could just be Scuttle
but I mean look at all the scuttlebutt
that's gotten us where we are so far
with this deal right but but I mean that
that would if you wanted to play the
game of I'd never you know Bend to
anyone's will even on something that you
know in and of itself isn't necessarily
the hill many would die on it's the
he'll all die on because I'll die on
every Hill that's kind of his brand
right like there isn't a hill I won't
die on and then and then to have Elon
Musk come in and say well we're you know
you're going to be allowed to say that I
mean what an ultimate Victory there plus
that coupled with the daily wire
announcement everything else is like
Jordan Peterson's king of the world
Babylon be coming back at the same time
would be huge all that happened all
right let's see Bree Sullivan says are
you serious about Trump Banning people
it was reported I'm not saying it's
completely it's true because you know I
don't trust these media Outlets that
people were getting banned off true
social for pushing uh January 6
reporting like they were they were
saying like here's a January 6th the
committee is saying and doing and they
were getting banned I kind of feel like
I don't trust them when they report that
because it's probably you know leftists
and liberals going on Truth social and
breaking the rules but including January
6th so they could be like look look what
I was banned for and it's like yeah like
I said my friend Reid and I'm not going
to repeat it because we're on a YouTube
live stream but we'll put up stuff that
uh should not be violating what they
purport to be their terms but it's like
you know sacred cows in the in the in on
the right and uh and and very quickly
gets banned like minutes I don't know
true social but knowing him he's already
done it because he did it with all of
them
um so I'm sure he's done it with them
too
all right Anthony zavaro says Jordan
Peterson joining the daily wire was the
straw that broke the camel's back that
made me join daily wire plus the culture
War pendulum swings
and and I will say this too
the more power the daily wire generates
through subscriptions the more they're
able to sign people like Jordan Peterson
which will in turn make the snowball get
bigger and bigger and bigger and uh I
gotta say daily wire is the new CNN I
don't mean that in a way that it's
derogatory CNN at one point was
groundbreaking it was the 80s right they
they were like we're going to do news 24
7. and then all of a sudden you had this
big deal this they created the 24-hour
news cycle and it was a big deal it was
a cultural shift and now they're
imploding and the daily wire is taking
off displacing you know they're the new
upstart
um they're the first to do a streaming
video on demand service but uh I gotta
say get woke go broke has never been
truer these big streaming networks are
just resting on their Laurels yes we
know what CBS is and so people sign up
for it but the daily wire is building
and proving they're they're actually
building something new they're earning
their place that's meritocracy and we're
going to see it their movies are going
to improve their shows are going to
improve and we're going to be like yo I
didn't want to watch have you guys
watched Miss Marvel
have you guys seen it did you watch it I
didn't but we talked about it on the
show a few times and I am watching it
was cartoonishly bad it is beyond it is
a it is okay I heard they actually use
the word latinx yes let me tell you
about Miss Marvel Miss Marvel is a show
which is a high school course on British
colonialism in Pakistan that's what the
show is because I swear they say
partition every five minutes and then
there's a scene in one of the episodes
where they're like they're in uh they're
in Pakistan and then they're like
walking and they're talking about like
you've got magic powers by the way this
is a house where people were forced to
live because of partition colonialism
had terrible cause terrible problems
with this country and then start walking
and I'm like what what did that have to
do with anything in the show their
Genies being attacked by the government
and you want to stop to pause to give me
a lesson on partition yo that's most
important the show is so bad but you
know I watch this because like I want to
know I want I you know I want to review
it myself and I'm a big fan of Marvel
and watching this I'm like come on man
like I think Miss Marvel's cool I played
The Avengers video game I dig it but
just I'm not here for a lesson on
partition and British colonialism in
India okay so can we just move the story
on as to why this little girl like this
teenager's got magic powers and can we
just have fun and Inspire and create a
strong female character who saves the
day the answer is no no
well and it's I think I mean not unless
you recognize partition that's right you
know oh she travels back in time to
partition I I try I try to picture the
condescension and the low effort that's
being put into trying to create
so-called diversity by saying you know
you know remember Thor well now she's
black and it's like how you know why not
instead I mean there's all sorts of
African folklore why not create new
characters and have them be black and
female or gay or whatever else like why
take existing characters and say oh it's
okay we're gonna include you it handed
me down because it is it's a character
assassination
of fan base well and it's also it's it
it's done out of contempt
that's a great way to make money but
it's not about making money okay I think
it's ID logs who have nothing to lose
but even if it's ideological right like
if I have this ideological desire to
spread diversity this isn't diversity
this is like uh this is It's almost like
a weird kind of black face like it's
like it's like saying this character
this you know and again I'm using Thor I
don't even know if they've changed Thor
but they changed Thor to a woman but
it's Natalie Portman okay well but
that's just she she took possession of
mjolnir well but but if I don't think
the storyline for for the Mighty Thor is
actually as bad as a lot of people
complained about and I I picked I don't
follow any of this but I've just seen so
many examples of like okay this
character is now you know gay or black
or Muslim or whatever else and it's like
why not instead have a new character
that is that and that is uniquely that
person like it that seems like that
would be far more powerful and
empowering and inclusive in in in in in
embracing diversity than just saying
this one's black now
right it's like here's an existing
character uh we're gonna just make him
Latino I guess so that it's like no no
make it make a new hero right Thor's
unique because it's whoever picks up the
hammer becomes Thor like Eric Masterson
was one at one point there was a guy
before Eric Masterson yeah that might
not have been a good example but just
Superman or whatever it's like yeah I
think it's because they are not as
creative as like Stanley they're afraid
to take risks and to create something
that'll fall on its face that's
something that's about to fall apart
they're not disrupting and creating new
things then you end up becoming stagnant
they're pod people who are wearing these
institutions like skin suits they're
lizards let's read some let's read some
more all right Bonnie says Albert here
can you guys please just Annex us it
would be amazing and no more Trudeau had
so many scandals he should be in jail
only prime minister in history to be
found to violate ethnic laws they have
oil too dude I thought of that while we
were talking about how badass how
awesome if we were all I mean I think if
they saw if if the American Canada
became one United States and we were all
like living in this decentralized
Freedom State like able to do it Mexico
is the United States of Mexico that's
the name of the country so like if we I
understand that centralization isn't the
isn't the goal I don't want like a
federal government controlling the
Canadians but dude we're basically the
same people with like these similar
ideals and like it's very
I think I want to work from the bottom
up to nullify the bad crap we have and
then export that elsewhere like create a
domino effect of people more locally and
More in tune with their actual Community
their actual culture and culture by the
way does not have to be geographical or
ethnic or anything like that it can be
values based it could be an online
community that spans the entire Globe
community-based uh decentralized order
with a eye towards nullifying the bad
centrally planned order that's being
imposed on them that's something that
can become essentially worldwide but
it's focused at the local level and it's
focused on the empowerment of the
individual and on voluntary Solutions
over bad coerced ones all right let's
read this one we got uh Al bidam says
Tim per the UCMJ uniford uniform code
for military Justice if a crime were to
happen on a military base or off the
federal authorities base commander
defense counsel have jurisdiction over
the military member first as far as
active duty goes yes and on the military
base they have like exclusive rights to
criminally try but the the point I was
trying to get at with that is what
happens when you get to the point where
the ideology is too strong and someone
in the state says this person who lives
in our city took a baby
against its will to be killed on a
military base imagine it this way if
there's a baby kidnapped and brought
into a military base and then killed and
then the person comes back off you might
actually get people in the state rioting
and demanding Justice it may Then Fall
upon the federal government say okay
they literally killed a baby but if the
federal government doesn't recognize
that as a crime you could end up with
people rioting you could end up with
federal government saying we will do
nothing and that's the point of conflict
so it's uh it's like you were saying the
reality of power reality of power the
states have way more power at the state
level they got the guns they got the
numbers so it's just a question of I
understand it's not legal but secession
wasn't according to Buchanan either it
didn't stop them will we get to that
point where it reminds me of V for
Vendetta when the um was it the
inspector says someone will eventually
do something stupid and then it shows
the little girl skipping wearing the
mask and then the cop shoots her and
then all of the locals just walk up and
just beat the cop to death they don't
care what was legal at that point will
will we come to the point with abortion
and I've talked about this before if
blue state if if we get a national born
a national ban on abortion because
Republicans end up uh codifying it Mike
Pence says he wants it nationwide just
not enforced by the federal government
Sheamus says he wants a national ban
if blue States then say no we won't stop
do let me ask you this do you think
there are there's one person in this
country who would who would take it upon
themselves is to stop them were at
codified illegal Nationwide one person
to stop uh the the implementation
federal government Congress codifies
because Republican sweep in November
then Trump gets reelected and he signs
this bill and then abortion is banned
across the country California says nope
we're still going to keep doing it do
you think there is one person in the
United States for anywhere that would be
like I'm going to go to California to
stop it oh uh to stop The Californians
yeah yes and it's quite possible the
federal government even does because the
federal government says it's illegal
standoff yeah then the federal
government will go and enforce the law
which they say supersedes if the will is
there because you know marijuana is
illegal but they're not going into these
states so it really just depends on if
they're willing to do it that's the
point the willingness to reach that that
level of of clash the will of the people
that's part of the reality of power is
is whose side are the majority of people
on because they're also the ones voting
they're the ones making these kinds of
like decisions of what they're willing
to tolerate so I mean there are many
different factors when you're figuring
out power It's Not Just Guns and numbers
it's also like the perception of what's
right or wrong by the by the plurality
or the majority and all those things
play into that I mean it can become a
pretty big mess pretty quickly all right
Stephen uh Geiger says USMC vet here how
will the military be able to provide
abortions with the hide amendment in
effect that's a good point good question
they say they currently do oak is
federal government can't provide funding
for it
but if but they said they currently do
now there is the very serious Clash of
has the
wow I can't give you I don't remember
this has the height Amendment been
repealed yeah tell me about the height
Amendment so the height amendment is
basically an amendment that was added at
some point uh to I believe Medicare
funding uh that said that uh that the um
that the federal government dollars
cannot be used directly for abortions so
even like Title IX funding for Medicare
uh or Medicaid
um supposedly isn't supposed it can go
to Planned Parenthood but it can't go
towards the abortions it can go towards
everything else and then that frees up
money for the abortions but it can't go
towards the actual abortions this would
be a case where they are actually
funding abortions but now I'm trying to
remember if the Hyde Amendment is still
in in effect or not I think it is all
right we got Jessie Meek he says I'm a
member of the timcast website and simply
can't send a pitch I've tried several
times a day for 10 days now and can't
even report the problem is there a
problem with the site
um I don't know we'll check we'll look
into that to make sure but we've also we
don't accept pitches anymore right
because we can't we can't shut down the
email yeah we shut down the email we
can't we can't accept pitches so um too
many legal implications because if you
if you send a pitch and then I don't
even read it but then we end up making
the thing coincidentally you can come at
me for it's just doing your idea and
it's not worth it it just makes people
angry it's it's just better that we
don't do it
um it's it's not so bad so it's it's
just basically like
we we don't want there to be any um
misconceptions or it will because you
couldn't respond right right right right
and then people are like I had this idea
and then we had a similar idea and it's
just like it's better it's better that
we just take um solicited pitches
directly which is the reality of the
industry you know I will say we try to
be Scrappy and punk rock but every day
we learn exactly why businesses function
the way they do and
um
you know I've got I've got friends at
bigger companies I won't name them uh
big CEOs and they're alike it really is
just the more people you hire the more
you become corporate not not by choice
by regulation so like we're learning a
lot about what the government mandates
and it's crazy you know people are like
man my job sucks the way they do these
policies I'm like oh those are legal
those are legally enforced policies like
the government makes them do it so
that's the reality of growing a big
company yep nothing you can do about it
so it's like stop your company from
growing too big so you can stay being
small and just having fun or try and
have a big cultural impact and then the
government steps in and says now you
have to do all of these things and then
they're like or then we can move our
banks to Panama and become a
multinational Mega Corp that lives
outside of government bounds like you
see why that happens yeah you either
there there is not you are not allowed
to climb a steady ladder you have to
choose a lane and the lane is either you
grow Pat you grow up to a certain point
you don't get any bigger because it's
not worth the hassle you dive into it
become a company that you know is making
way more money but is just subject to so
much regulation it becomes almost
stagnant as a result or you go to the
next level where you just own everything
and you see like someone like Jeff Bezos
like Amazon literally has gone through
each of those stages uh and to the point
now where Jeff Bezos is like buying
entire media companies and you know
putting out hit pieces against the
Pentagon because they didn't approve his
10 billion no bid deals and like it's
almost like becoming Lex Luthor who
originally star started his company out
of a small office and went from small
business all the way up to you know uh
the biggest Mega company ever almost so
that's that's that's the progression of
what happens and that's all because of
the fascist corporate system that
government imposes on the market all
right B Anderson says if they're not
going to enforce abortion bans on
federal property what's going to stop
them from not enforcing acts against
little ones crimes
I'm thinking about this this is
interesting
I tried looking up instances instances
in which something is illegal at the
state level but not the federal level
and I can't it's really hard to find
it's usually not that way right yeah but
now we're there yeah so let's say
um the government says you know what
marijuana federally legal because the
Democrats are really pushing it we got
some libertarian types in Congress it
may happen but then you have a state
like West Virginia where it's illegal
and they're going to say yeah well
federal law supersedes state law but
hold on hold on there's they're taking
the Law off the books just because it's
not criminalized the federal level
doesn't mean you can do it so what
happens then if you have people in West
Virginia
going on to Federal bases to do illegal
drugs as as West Virginia would see it
are they going to be like we're okay
with this what if it goes even crazier
what if the Democrats actually say like
heroin and now you have heroin addicts
wandering off Federal property for
whatever maybe a military base and
they're all strung out and they're
causing problems in the state and the
state's like we got to arrest these
people
like I don't think the state would
tolerate people going into a military
base committing serious crimes and then
coming out the thing that might be worth
looking into is post prohibition you had
you know it was legal but regulated at
the federal level but there were so many
dry States and towns for quite some time
after that the dry States now it's more
like you know you can't drink it in a
restaurant or whatever but like there
used to be like it's still illegal in
this town do not be caught drinking or
possessing it here it would be
interesting to see if there were any
cases where like there was a military
base there and there were people getting
drunk on base and then you know
wandering out into town and whether or
not they tried to arrest them because of
that I would guess that it would be no
that it would be because Federal usurp
State uh and it is federal property that
they would likely say no you can't do
that but again reality of power comes
into place if it if it reaches a
cultural level if it reaches a political
level where it is most politically
expedient for the people in charge at
that State to say you know what we're
going to enforce it anyway we don't care
what the Supreme Court Court says we
don't say care what the White House says
we don't care what anyone says we're
going to do it anyway then the rule of
law doesn't even mean anything all right
we'll get one more here quickly saw six
as the Army doesn't allow it under
article 119a and Tricare does not cover
it you need an ETP signed by a general
officer after your provider gave you a
memo saying you will die if you keep
going perhaps they're just blowing hot
air the Pentagon is just saying we're
going to keep doing it but they really
don't do it anyway it could very well be
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and hit
the Bell hit the Bell right hit that
Bell and head over to timcast.com become
a member because we're only about 800
and some odd thousand subscribers away
from catching up to the Daily wire so if
we can get if we can get 800 that well
if we can get all 1.3 million people to
subscribe we'll be beating yeah okay but
uh subscribe support our work because we
are trying to get to that point as well
yes doing new shows hiring more and more
people we're expanding quite rapidly you
can follow the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me personally at timcast
Spike you want to shout anything out
absolutely uh if you want to follow me
I'm Spike Cohen I'm on all social media
I also have a show uh actually a
multi-time a week show on muddied Waters
media uh that's muddywatersmedia.com we
too are a scan 800 and so thousand away
from uh subscribers away from beating uh
the daily wire so if you join us over at
anchor.fm Muddy Waters you can become a
subscriber today uh and uh if you want
to find out more about the Grassroots
Revolution for Liberty that we are
building to set communities free and
grow the Liberty Movement in America uh
go to you are thepower.net and see how
you can get involved
you can find me on Instagram or WeChat
at closer Kitty sometimes I post
articles on timcast.com and I promote
them there and I also want all of you to
go in droves to pop culture crisis on
YouTube and subscribe and hit the bell I
guess I never say that
um I gotta pop in and talk about Miss
Marvel
I want to do a review I'm going to be
alive
I can't do it yeah if I get work done on
time you guys go live at three I have to
get down yeah come tomorrow I'll be on
oh okay Tim on pop culture I can't do it
tomorrow but we'll see we'll see maybe
next week with Miss Marvel yeah well we
go live every weekday at 3 P.M Eastern
Standard Time and noon Pacific so come
join us that's right come join us
tomorrow three o'clock P.M Eastern
Standard Time pop culture crisis I'll be
there I'm looking forward to it I'm Ian
Crossland from iancrosslin.net hit me up
anytime you like Spike great to meet you
man good talking to meet you too thank
you so much I mean it was really concise
really nice I appreciate that thank you
man see you later very nice pop culture
crisis evening I'm really glad they
crossed over the 30 000 threshold and
excited for what the future holds for
them for sure Brett works very hard on
that show and Mary's great addition too
you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com it's Sarah patchlitz as
well as the site that Andy Made For Me
called sour patchlands.me we will see
you all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out bye guys